indeed looks like we're ready so she is
getting all blurred out there
mm-hmm come on cheated come on shake
that yeah I'm ready when you are man I'm
ready my let's do this thing
all right the free one what's that I
don't look too washed out here their
grand face good grab face brother you
need you an afternoon nap that's what
you need to be like we have wind ooh I
get that the adrenaline is high we go
get to it
no that was not a morning yeah all right
let's do this all right and we are live
welcome to the last word with Lord
kognito Andy bonta's the camp fire is
very hot shadow keep has arrived we're
at launch week we made it e we made it
baby are you really feeling good having
fun you know burning the candle at both
ends as well but having a blast
honestly just felt like everyone's like
an October 1st kid here Kent October 1st
gate here and then I finally get here
it's just like it was just like it was a
lot so it's been fun
how's your week been it's been a lot man
there's been a lot I mean I was doing
good I mean you talked and um I thought
I was prepared very well I had a great
first day and as far as grinder grind I
was in my mo a lot too Lord addict you
know I had to take it over to Xbox with
him you begged me Larry no but although
just grinding out cross platforming and
then armed missed one day of grinding
which just I was very upset as you know
you got this you got the very distraught
frustrated text from me
you know beefy life took over life's to
go huh life happens it's okay when I
bounce back let's come back today back
in the grind totally irresponsible and
playing that's the way I want to play
[Laughter]
what about you baby you got to be fried
right now like you are hardcore going at
it bro
uh yeah one character I think my Titans
916 my warlocks 919 Wow literally
running and I'm not even not even
remotely the highest like dados and
glads and stuff I saw that I was like 9
24 9 26 there they are I'm there
so no even my my possible grind has been
I mean I've been doing a decent amount
of it soul or playing with a friend or I
went back through and helped a friend
with some quests and help somebody get
the new fancy rocket launcher which
we'll talk about
he's helped on that quest so there's
certain pieces there are some crazy like
there's a ridiculous glitch that I saw
moons all out in the morning oh if you
learn if you started on your warlock
your Titan can have a huge benefit so
daddy's my situation yeah I was the
exact opposite so I start my Titan yeah
I just yeah I honestly didn't know we're
just gonna jump into this podcast guys
parallel leap in I honestly wasn't sure
when we started this thing when I booted
it up for one how'd the boot up go for
you how the had the initial kick off
about that it was kind of rough out here
these streets made of edom I took a nap
and I said my long shot to Lord at it
cuz I overslept never what act was like
it is time where are you and I gotta
give my fireteam shelter sinister sound
the Lord let me give you a reason why
these two are the most light level
chasing I'm not waiting for you kind of
people right these are the people who
they were what they won't blaze ahead in
the strike they'll leave you behind and
okay what's going on hurry up and get
you behind over that these are these
guys these are the light chasers in my
clan right so it's one I thought I said
my along eat so you know I just having
to good asleep I - good then I see my
phone kept going off off he's
where are you and I'm like he's like
dude we're waiting in orbit and I'm like
all right my bad um get me cold up I'll
wake it up and then I I dig salute them
and they literally waited 30 to 40
minutes in launch they were able to get
in I was able to get in so I would say
about 35 minutes after launch it's like
12 yeah yeah 12 your time your time
right and then for me 1 1 p.m. sorry I
got it if it was 1:00 p.m. Eastern when
I started I got in 130-140 straited no
wait no cue but what we noticed is as it
the day went on I guess you know 3
o'clock heads to school kids and you
just started to see connecting the
Destiny servers connecting the deficit I
was able to play but connecting the
density servers and then I forgot what
time it was I'm gonna guess maybe 5:00
p.m. on me about for us that sounds
about yeah I had a bright day did it was
like Shing like someone cut the power
mm-hmm and everybody was in orbit and
I'm just like yeah this is this is the
new like crew they do like you like - so
what about you how was your experience
tell me about okay actually I got I got
about the first cuz I was on able to log
in after about yeah there's like the
half hour kind of initial queue
everybody had and they had about two and
a half hours same thing so about two and
half hours of playing and then yeah
about four o'clock my time so I was like
you know 12:30 to 3:30 or something like
that three hours somewhere in there and
just like oh yeah it just straight up
gone shut it down may as well go take a
nap
I kept like checking Twitter so let it
turn like notifications on my phone went
in the other room tried to take like
take a nap close the eyes because I knew
would be kind of a long first night and
yeah got a couple hours and then finally
actually I got a friend back on who
hadn't been playing in a while so they
jump back in so it's been probably
something similar for the first day at
least was yeah so I mean I mean you have
to imagine what they had to do and ever
blue birds were asking me like why does
everything have to be on the same day I
was like I think the battle Nexus teams
like some contract or something but they
didn't have the
didn't have a choice when that happened
they couldn't be like hey you can start
playing on steam two weeks earlier with
like new light and stuff and like so
you'd give the new light players a
chance to come in and not smash the
servers on the first day you know yeah
there were it was so and then you had me
so yeah new light you'd shadow keep an
you had steam all on the first day well
they had 24-hour server maintenance and
like it came back up and when I logged
in I for about half an hour I was like
cool so like the game technically
functioned I'd say their servers just
got smashed a little hard on that first
day most I probably wait yeah I think
they eventually came out and said it was
some type of database era that you know
first of all shout out to network
infrastructure teens because I'm gonna
be biased just from the simple fact that
obviously I work a ninety that is my
field and Dom people you know I just
like to see the internet troll but it's
funny cuz when people don't understand
what's going on and it's like well why
don't they have more servers like they
should have no because you understand
when you do testing you can do
real-world testing and there are
variables that do not present itself
unless sometimes it's live and it's it's
completely unforeseen even your most
stringent tests don't catch it you know
I'm saying and it was just cool actually
caught a cool thread of some devs and
some on just talking about it just like
educating people where it's like you
know like basically someone whose
analogy of like a train you know say
it's like this is the equivalent of the
tracks being severed and it's like well
you know you should just buy more more
trains going on but I mean yeah it's
absolute chaos well the other pieces too
it's like you are gonna have a big
influx on that day now by that'sa gonna
be your biggest point but in turn use
not to find a way to manage that you're
not gonna need to always have like you
don't need to have like a block of like
a hundred worth of server space bad
analogy but take 100 for that one peak
hi crazy time and then as things settle
on people don't login all at the same
time and then you need half of that
later on you don't need to double it for
like one point and then just overdo it
for the rest of time so mmhmm yeah it's
like I totally understood a figure it
was gonna happen it's like it's just how
some of those goes
still shows the game isn't dead so yeah
it doesn't bother me in that sense
either I may listen at the end of the
day you know we've been around the block
and one thing you realize with um MMO
launches you know for the most part I
mean I got to give division credit
because it had a great a great one they
had a great start but um with this kind
of a situation again I've never seen
namely one MMO that actually transferred
from one platform to another which
Blizzard to steam and I'm saying you had
cross save that was going on initially
and I'm saying all databases and
involved so to me the fact that they
just had it as long as four I would say
but always say downtown would you say
about two to three hours would you say
four hours would you say longer what
would you say I was like yeah the
initial like 30 minutes of just people
kind of getting in and then I think
after that it was mostly from the moment
they say hey well because he made it
announcement he like look we are
shutting only a couple hours I feel like
it was like 2 to 3 that's what I figured
considering all the variables involved I
thought it was impressive you know sad
or was impressive man this was a line
thank God they did cross save beforehand
right yeah you know and seriously that
would have been uttered chaos Oh bro
that's a lot you know so shout out to
them I still see little minor things
nothing too crazy I think I know it's
team right now I've been playing a
little bit PC recently that um I don't
know about you've experienced this but
where your name is are you know lore
Cognito
and there for me it's like I'm Arnold
Parker and I'm like way the cast yeah
they've been tweeting out or it's like
even ours where our joking client name
it's like it's like half of it sometimes
so yeah initials are not the four it's
just - yeah absolutely absolutely so
I'll be again - stuff I'm not going
crazy for the most part man things are
working and they'd let's just kudos to
Bungie man they those guys were working
extra hard man that day I could only
imagine what that net second was with
that network infrastructure room was and
those guys came through like a champion
on just the absolute chaos at one point
in their it's just like the whole
buildings on fire
and they're just sitting around like oh
yeah an angry tweets gonna I pay I see
people talking about
want a refund on my coma and the
Internet is ridiculous I hate some of
that crap to angels I mean yeah I can
mature I did one issue do I got it I got
it I got AB written up though
um basically so shall i do game sharing
on xbox shots and he's my game shape
heart so what happened was we get he did
the deluxe cuz I'm all steam already
just picked it up here on my own but 4xy
he's I got you don't worry about it so
boom
you know if I'm coming to the lesser
platform but on yes so basically you
know I got two deluxe from booting up
and ready to go had everything how my
DLC but the season rankings aka battle
pass was locked for me and I was like
alright well maybe it's a network issue
you know let me
chill out let's see what's going on and
come to find out that I believe that's a
count based in so what happened is even
though he brought that the DLC and all
that stuff I get put that bad that
season rake is individual that's what
that was so I'm like alright you get the
little ten bucks get out my life I'm not
gonna crazy you know then but oh yeah
shot the ultimate bill yeah saying I
know a lot of people didn't realize it
basically that is a count base so if you
do game sharing and if you're wondering
why if you're the person who bought it
you're fine but if you're the person
who's sharing from the person who bought
it but you get the DLC expansion to
pre-order pack you get the bonuses but
I'm sitting there running around like
what's this Ariana's vow everybody's
talking about I don't have it I have I
have the top path I got a padlock so
budget yeah yeah favorite ten bucks I
got my Ariane is now so I'm I'm happy
now how much have you you've been mostly
on Xbox then it sounds like or yeah the
first day was probably I say overall I'm
probably been about seventy thirty xbox
with now PC like last night I put in
serious where it goes yes that's really
my first time you
chance to turok you know on PC glorious
as it always is so you probably jumped
in I guess it's just funny like me and
my buddy were playing run around the
moon oh he was like man this is like
this is the moon like going around you
got anchors you got archers line but I
can't what happened here with like the
crash tracks like it looked obviously
there was some obviously it's not
exactly the same like the right the
ground is in a bit of upheaval
earthquake cracks and stuff like that
with the green globe but he and I were
joking is like this is how I remember it
looking so is that nostalgia feel of
like to go back and play like a Super
Nintendo game or n64 and be like oh this
doesn't quite cuz in your mind it's like
at the time you probably play to be like
oh this looked amazing it was really
cool and then you go back and you're
like oh it's not and we're talking this
was like the moon was 2014 yeah five
years ago so I'm I've years ago and then
especially because we were on console
then on regular ps4 and now we're
playing on you know steam on fancy PC so
it's just even then it's like in your
mind you're like this is what I remember
it looking like this is not what it
looked like so there's no way yeah 30
frames per second field of view like
just more detailed tech just everything
and then you finally get your like yep
moon looks good it felt good to be back
like just to be driving around the moon
oh I know this area oh I know this area
oh oh was it what yo you deal with it
right now you hear me yeah yes it was
feels I mean let me shout out a policy
because um it's not the lot to ask me if
Adam one was a show before and he's been
at the campfire a great guest yeah he
said it perfectly he wrote it all he's
like look maybe to an outsider they will
say oh look they're recycling content on
some level you know whatever whatever
right and he says look he just said
that's fair to some extent he said but
as a destiny fan she's like I don't yeah
he's like this is the most nostalgic
feels like you remember what you were
doing you go in the Hellmouth when you I
mean they're just serving things that
it's like this what made you fall in
love with the game you know like I was
reciting Dinklage lines
as I'm fronting the door you know it
comes to hive you know is it for the
more like you know yeah wait on there
way too many times oh my god bro
tremendous and just like the little
nuances and just even to see the
differences it's almost felt like you've
been away for a while so you see almost
a destructive thing is just a lot of
changes going on but I will say this the
first mission especially set it off me
like once we get fit it was like let's
say we'll try and separate us today and
everybody so if you are worried about
those will give a big disclaimer and
leave that stuff towards the end but
yeah yeah we get to it Bay whoa yeah
some feels major major feels man major
feels good stuff yeah it was just I mean
it was cool to be going around and to go
just like even the titles is like
world's grave and archers line and all
of wisdom and you know circle of bones
I'm just seeing all those titles I'm
like yep yep yep just hitting that
checklist in my head of all those places
and then we got obviously new locations
and things like that again will probably
cover campaign spoilers and stuff as we
go towards the end mm-hmm
because that's where most of the
spoilers are at at least until whatever
happens tomorrow
but so far so I'm kind of asking like
and we'll just kind of bounce back and
forth trying to go one thing you and
we'll just go kind of specifics as we go
through spoiler stuff save it to the end
should for your launch I can't want to
just bounce back give me something
really good you light like a big
positive and then something you'd like
to see changed about just the launch
overall the state of the game everything
like that so and we'll just bounce them
back and forth just anything you've been
noticing so state of the game okay this
is like or just anything you've seen
like what's a change that came in shadow
keep or what's something you'd like to
ask a change that didn't quite happen
we'll just trade them for a little bit
because there's a lot of stuff with the
launched even just a little bitty thing
so yeah first okay
let's get to it let's get to one of our
biggest last word confrontations that we
will revisit which was the season
ranking almost very curious to see how
component you know how I felt very
strongly about that yeah you know
especially the whole exotic thing and
yada yada yada
you know and I got it met man it didn't
feel intrusive
it literally felt beneficial it felt
like hey I need this like hook me up
with that you're like yeah like you know
materials here and there and um yeah a
mess I gotta say you know in your
defense II didn't feel any fiction to
start with the smartest stop with the I
told you so's course he does this yard
he eating this is when he no he right
here I'm the first admit if I'm wrong
I'm wrong you know saying and I will say
in this case I felt it was not intrusive
I felt it was actually additive um you
know I looked forward to actually
picking up what a luck shout out to my
Ariana's Val which I was very happy
about you know maybe I thought about
that boy I get there yeah you would get
today I know you get to that and um you
know that was that I think that's so
that's my first one
seizing rank you know so far it has the
cog approval I didn't feel it was crazy
yes no I mean I I've enjoyed so far like
getting there the level and it feels
good seeing the big number the reward so
far have been nothing over the top
either a fight we finally figure out
what all those little the little shields
with each little symbol on you're
getting little bonuses once a little exp
bonus as you go through and then you can
earn it a little quicker one of them's
by the way ya taught you can the
marianas Val there's progress up to
level 22 don't even try and worry about
Tony Atlas don't even worry about the
catalyst Ontario about until you're a
season ranked 22 especially with the
premium the season pass because it will
literally triple your progress on that
quest at the end because it'll double it
at a point and then it triples it ranked
22 and I crossed over that last night
and I was just like yeah that's that's
better cuz I did like one strike with it
and then I did another and I was still
at 1% I was like how long is this gonna
take and it was just because I was like
messing around was a solar up and it's
just what I had at the moment and I was
just kind of going help so yeah it was
vagabond of screaming like
effective yeah so that's one of those
that was um but no I mean all the season
pass overall like the little bonuses are
cool you'll get you know a little it'll
give you all those little basically the
shields that we didn't know our little
bonuses in places it ups ups your chance
that drops rates for the armor for the
weapons from different activities it's
just it's really pretty minor stuff so
people worried about like pay to win
yeah there's exotics towards the end if
you get there but generally I would say
that most of that stuff is a really
really minor so by the time you do get
to the end yeah you've probably earned
it oh yeah absolutely yeah absolutely I
mean the top path so far at least the
meetups I know it kind of quiets offer
and like mid-30s or so when you yeah
they get the gun again but so far the
top path was like the upgrade modules in
the bottom path with the gear and things
like that I haven't been picking up the
gear mm-hmm cuz I got the full package I
got the first package which came with
your set but as you go through the
levels it you don't have to pick them up
Frye small so you can actually so like
if you're missing a piece later on
you're gonna end up basically having two
copies of everything and you could do a
per character so mm-hmm
smart man's fault man laid out so we
doing we doing uh now we doing uh
whatnot so like oh yes no mines gonna be
it not so like on the other side of that
so okay let's go so season pass rink one
BAM exotic hand cannon that just felt
too soon oh okay let's talk about yeah
just the hand is this what I mean if you
get to see if you buy shadow key which
comes with the season pass you literally
can look in there go and you get your
you get your set of armor which is cool
cuz honestly their armor 2.0 so that's
like that's not game breaking that's
just one of many many rules you're gonna
have that's fine but yeah just give you
the the exotic I know there are other
exotics but there's not that many there
are never enough you to say box one here
you know like if everybody got it at 35
maybe but I just think that one came too
early and it's like I think we all
probably
we figured that before and like the
exotic Ingram it could be a I don't even
it could be a duplicate of anything but
just the brand-new gun the brand-new
hand cannon right there in your face on
rain quad just it seems let me savor the
moment give it to give me that at like
rank seven on the free head yeah I like
this but let's be real they sold it they
saw cousin must I went in their language
but it went in it like you know what I
gotta get it like I it was bothering me
that my per season ranked wasn't working
I'm seeing everybody else with this gun
and I'm go where did it drop and they
like no no is it's the ranking so I
gotta do it with fox game sharing which
at some point helps to explain that to
me later but mmm-hmm is that just like
somebody else owns the game and you can
play it because they own it
yeah bit pretty much use digital sharing
right so it did you only so basically if
we link our accounts right yeah anything
I buy automatically gets downloaded to
your Xbox so so basically you should
split the cost with your friends like
okay you know what you get boy Lance
I'll get destiny and I'm saying and this
is totally legit this is not a legal
stuff even Xbox is aware of it this was
part of the initial vision of digital
stuff but again they did a terrible job
explaining it and then what end up
happen is they left it in they just left
that portion they took all the bad stuff
out with the DRM but they left the
portion of the sharing in so if you cut
their encouraged digital purchases so
that's what it so if you buy something
and then it will automatically get
downloaded to my Xbox as well so it's
really cool as a gamer you can be very
financial frugal it's really cool you
know I'm saying DLCs everything Danno
said it's a great ex play oh yeah it's a
may aware of it I've spoken to
executives you know Phil spent today
they're all aware of it they are
encouraging the digital resolution is
what they is plus let's be really I got
a you know do BA merchandise box costs
and all that other stuff so save money
yeah yeah but in the grand scheme then
if you're doing that it's like Destiny's
still gonna be like you actually got to
have the license you can't you can't go
full free mode on us come on now the hey
it's the first game we've played
made like thousands we've been doing
for years and this is the first game I
can't comment okay I don't know
fortnight I don't know maybe fortnight
is the same role I don't I don't play
for it like that so it's right oh that's
free you don't have to pay so you just
but there is a pass there is a nail I
don't they go like a battle pass yeah
they do the pass I'm curious shout to
the fortnight guys anybody on
Playstation or Xbox let me know love a
feeling if you wouldn't share that one
because it is free anyway so then you
probably wouldn't have your own battle
pass but usually if that person buys it
you know I put it put it this way when
sinister buys the Destiny season pass
like season black alambre and all that I
get go away hmm
what out purchasing any like that's it's
literally a free ride all the way
through so I'm just curious but anyway
lo story show you that I do feel you
really the the it felt a little yeah
yeah that was just like it was just too
much of like cute like exotic something
we've got quests coming for multiple
exotics we know down the road you
finished the campaign there's one at the
end save it until you're at least 900
please save yourself the light level and
that but that's at least through the
campaign that's like that's your you
know your new reward you get a new piece
of armor
sadly I'm wondering if that's just the
only new armor though yeah so I was like
well kind of get into some of those
things but it's like just a gut like
login click a box here he goes like no
that one I didn't I didn't agree and
well I think I was like I was even like
was like getting that at Rank 1 I think
I haven't said that before it came was
like the mid Engram find but the mid
like first one gun yeah guns are a
little more special especially because I
agree guns are the game-changer of how
like your gameplay feels the armor is
usually a bit more passive so and and I
do agree with you also in a sense that
let's be real and this was another
concern of mine was from what we've seen
as far as world drop exotics no no that
was quests there's only there's one
armed armor for my understanding per
class right yeah I mean that was the
stuff that kind of showed and images and
previews and things and you get that
from
end of the campaign hmm which is kind of
given to you he doesn't get out of it
you play your character you're gonna
have it
exactly so yeah so did I guess you now
you add this giant now here's my that's
funny now we kind of go on 180 on the on
the battle bed season right my bad thing
goes back to the season right but it's
actually something I just found out all
right how can I work out but let's say
it's an egregious thing no but I don't
know if you'd know I shout out to cactus
he's a great video out and um apparently
when you get to rank 26 there is a fire
team XP boost I just got it well guess
who I'm playing away from now Oh guess
who's gonna be in orbit with you so
apparently yeah like you get the UM the
whatever low bounties you do and if I
grab up all the the shadow keep ones and
you know we stand in long as I'm in a
fireteam with you you could be in a loss
ex I could be in a loss sector we could
be on the moon and we're getting I don't
know say double or triple the XP
administer
one's already maxed out there artifact
alright so yeah
about this eliminate double what it was
just like two percent more or something
small like that is that a lot bigger or
broken or something I don't I don't know
if it's broken - you know I don't know
the percentages yet but shout out to
cactus he's got a video right there I
was put it up last night and I was
floored he would like yet like literally
within eight minutes they were going up
a level in eight minutes of XP were they
doing just so basically you you got
whoever's the guy that had the level 26
fire team boosts then they're going to
the moon they're grabbing up air all of
Eris's bounties right no you going out
on both of you jazz long as you don't
and you know because a lot of that stuff
is shoot this kill that go and loss
sector filling up you know you do one or
two you're filling up a level then you
come back rinse repeat
hmm literally and I'm just like I don't
know Dan I don't know if it stacks one
another fire team member but I know
everyone reaps the benefit of this bonus
so double its Whaley big it was like a
small percent it may be but from what
they're saying if you're doing it in
conjunction with her bounties you're
moving very fast once that person gets
that so yeah so a shot of the black when
it says 2% but it looks like the bounty
XP was doubled on turn yeah something's
going on I don't know if that was
intended but it that's the new hustle
y'all get success somebody up above was
saying Giggs is already 950 I'm like
holy oh yeah so what would think about
that plus light level from the artifact
and he maxing that bad boy out
yep
yeah there are things in there hmm I
mean in the grand scheme of all of this
stuff yeah they're gonna be able to jump
into master stuff before it's probably
like available
what if they kind of cheese the level
and get it up high enough we'll just
have to see and it's a learning step but
yeah it's a learning day I always I will
say this I always was surprised that day
I will admit I was surprised that they
made an unlimited cap with that well we
noticed a like thee the amount of
experience it takes to add that bonus
power on the artifact gets bigger as you
go like every other level almost mmm it
was like it was like 500k next on a 6/10
next week actually 7:20 when I saw Daddo
like at one point so when like yeah I
might get up to like +8 but then if like
if you're thinking how much experience
you need for like plus 20 it's gonna be
like 2 million it's gonna be like
they're gonna be big leaps as you get
farther along that's why they said
there's gonna be a point where it's like
based on how much time is like literally
in a day they probably figured that out
to see what its gonna take to get up
there but you'll probably be able to be
like 950 and get like maybe 30 power
bonus for those master things but
getting to like 1,100 that's gonna be a
lot that is gonna be now if this glitch
is busted then we'll see but
intentionally yeah it's meant to be
pretty slow like you might be able to
get up to you know yeah it may be
something they Jase need to adjust the
release of that specific bonus yeah
maybe later in the past or something
like that week or if it's a glitch that
with what the percentage of experience
is given then they just need to tweak
that yeah
200% instead of 2% that's uh that's a
typo somewhere on some data number and
somebody's gone
whoo yeah so for me a positive we'll
just kind of keep bouncing back and
forth repeatable bounties something I
never knew I wanted but they are amazing
yes so every activity except Banshee and
actually shot has shot a to shackle
shotgun and doesn't he round up they are
aware that people want that stuff for
Banshee as well for a beautiful bounties
but yeah let's say you want to go play
crucible for a while
like hours and hours and you're like
well I don't know if I have that many
bounties because I've only got five mmm
go to your five go pick up a couple
extra oh you're done with bounties head
back in and go get a new stack and just
do it over and over and over so if you
really just love strikes or crucible or
gambit or the moon or the nightmares all
of those have repeatable bounties like
the other planets probably need to get
them Banshee could use to get them but
those are something I didn't even think
about but those are an awesome addition
because you're rewarded they needed a
way to roared you for time because
that's the season pass works that's the
way the bonus powers work and if I'm
gonna spend time like working on strikes
and going for random stuff I need that
extra boost is that nice incentive to
spend more time in there so that was
mine was absolutely that yeah I mean for
me um I think you know obviously
initially we talked on Twitter you know
I didn't get a chance to touch 2.0
initially no Sam now I'm in the minutia
I'm post 900 I'm in a messing around I'm
you know zan and you know I am liking
the potential of it I'm a little
frustrating I don't got to mods I need
you know a shout out to the scavenger
perks that are missing and you're saying
shout out to a couple of young Paragon
and intellect perks and stuff like that
but uh oh it's a brat what's going on
brother basement I radio our case so Lou
you know Sam but I will say like to cut
the configuration aspect the potential
is there man you know say like you you
you get that gear you get that gear and
then when I'm noticing is you may have a
void you may have a
uh what you call it um you know uh arc
Solar arc solar different ones right and
you have to look at when you get a mod
you have to look at which one it applies
to or as it's that's a big thing so now
what happens is I'm having this minutia
of sometimes you can get the same armor
piece but I'm not okay this one dropped
with five energy so I got more slots
initially off the top versus another one
and then okay but this one has these
mods that I have right now that are
really beneficial to said place there
right and it's like now it does feel
like every little piece of armor has
value and benefit and then as I'm
getting all cool mods like I got the one
where um you drop in special ammo for
you and your fireteam off the finisher
kills and I'm still one last time going
twice finishes I didn't know I knew we
all I'm down here doing Bruce Lee kicks
going like I'm having wild fun it's like
kicking a finishing move within your
head you're not gonna BAM pal laughs
just like old Batman comics sounds the
whole time bro I didn't realize I'd be
having so much buzz so now I'm that's
what led to my armor because i'm
specking stuff for some of my finishers
you know they you have finishes they've
got one with that like I'm wearing for
like a Bruce Lee one-inch punch you know
saying I'm waiting for I'm waiting for
like the Daniel son you listen with the
cake I'm waiting monetize this crazy
yeah so shout out to finishers me not
knowing I needed that in my life right
there yeah those are like no it's like I
jump on now and yeah finishers are
awesome they're they're in nice ways
that you get like an enemy low and you
instead of reloading just go finish him
you can do it that way it's and the
range like Tassie is out there on
twitter just exploding about the range
of these things because it's not a
normal male a you cover you cover some
ground to finish that thing it's not
like I'm gonna run across the room but
you're definitely gonna cover a few
staff you large steps to go get that
finisher off in it you can finish
through shields you can finish through
physical like hive shields
you can finish through a couple
different things and still just take
them out it's man I got the at the
season you get like the split kick and
that's pretty cool I'm still waiting I'm
like I just keep looking at the the heel
kick throughout the spinning heel kick
for the gin in that one so but I switch
over the warlock the warlock still
doesn't have my or maybe do I just have
to pick it up with the warlock on the
C's alas the wit using up the kick to
okay yeah I just didn't I just didn't
catch it so I just got a bullet from the
season pass so this season the art yeah
the season passes actually it has like
it's separate for character like you're
not getting it probably like the upgrade
modules and stuff every time but whether
it's the pieces of armor or apparently
like the spin kit like the finishing
moves and things like that those are you
got to pull them every time and I wasn't
catching that quite at first oh okay
okay yeah man I I just can't wait I this
thing or collections out there you go
it's in collect yeah there you go
collect okay cool cool shot the WD
Prescott yeah man like this this is
really cool
and I think it's just the potential is
so much fun like I'll just think of the
more things they could but yeah I didn't
know I would need this thing everybody
keeps joking about doing finishers to
curse they're all does that none I've
honestly not done that because I thought
that was a joke does that actually punch
them away or do they explode in your
face
um I died yeah I was like that seems
like telling the person to go walk up to
the edge and like scare him or something
like that that seems like a troll for
like a new Guardian or something as
opposed to actually get it not kill
yourself so you know what I do one what
I do want is okay you know how you can
only do a yellow bars in a ranking pile
right what I want is the ability to
think that you're gonna do it against
the boss and then the boss like does
something to you it throws you down like
no you can't do that
you're like look what catch exactly
would be fire like a funny troll but
that would be a lot of work for an
animation it would be a lot of hilarious
though there will be a Ledge
to be like no no no god you're that good
duties here you know that Curtis like
just like keeps pressing a sword down on
your head or something
[ __ ] Oh foot what else you get um so for
me it's probably gonna be let's see just
the feel of some of those new weapons
mmm
just kind of the way they just the
sounds even if they're not like like I'm
loving the way some hit and some don't
and everything's a little different but
the sounds of the new weapons they're
distinct oh yeah those sniper
tranquility yep oh not tranquil about
that gun boy oh that sound oh yeah so
sound of course on the guns I'll let you
jump into a sound thing that can
probably be easily your next thing big
big sounds big overarching yeah oh no
you know what
no actually what say my double take is
gonna be on the sound of the guns the
new ones are cool so far it's like our
first set of guns and then of course the
music when you log in stone wood I was
trying to set you up so yeah fro you see
my petition on Twitter right South
homegirl she's down with the from Bungie
CLD responsible for a lot of the
soundtrack of shadow key and man they
did a tremendous job what I like that
they do is right during that waiting
pair before launch
they release the soundtrack so what I
like to do is it kind of mentally gets
me into where they automatically with
the expansion yeah and I'm like Tanis
talk stuff right music is sets the tone
yeah this is spooky time now like we we
really out here you know say it were a
couple of tracks I'm like whatever this
board or mission is I need to know and
it ended up becoming the I can't
pronounce hahaha but Lagoon you know
that actually want to talk there you go
okay so and I was just like blown or
wait and there's one joint that got the
Gregorian chants going I'm just like
what is happening this is fire like this
is this is shadow key
I haven't obviously we haven't heard all
you know we got to see how everything
else plays out we have a rave we have
stuff we got to see but um for theme I'm
not gonna say it's the best music out of
all the experience doesn't have some
great music but I will say it's the best
at sticking to a theme throughout and
keeping you in nut and ominous yeah like
facts so I will say they did a
tremendous job so that that's definitely
a plus side yeah black wings described
it pretty well soundtrack reminds me of
the mix of a horror movie and Lord of
the Rings epically scary scary yes like
yes it's pretty good description because
it does feel like it has the grand scale
of like big events but it's also got
that undertone of like yeah moons
haunted mm-hmm
shout out to me omental he's digging the
exotic and can't believe Ariana like it
so far I know I was like I got it early
but what do you think of it so far
at first I want to do a straight in the
bush I did not like it effort yeah I was
like hey and then I sit cuz you don't
had that stupid kick and I was like it's
a monster kick on that reload I'm like
what is I was literally about to turn I
you know what made me stick with it one
of those little um you know those things
that the what you call it there's
something of greed to something of this
to something of that essence single
assets there you go so one of them
forced me to use hand cannons yeah
alright well as well use you know the
big you know bulldozer let's go so I
grabbed it and I started working on I
started acting like it was a sniper and
I was just but see it doesn't do a great
job of explaining functionality when
your site was giant scope on the top oh
listen man I like to replay the text and
the flavor tags a tell me really what
this thing was doing I mean it said a
little bit but I just didn't I didn't
feel the functionality was explained
well but anyway here's the end of it
grab a bad boy up
seen some Hogan's from down the block
glide them up and I was like yo this
is taking chunks I'm like oh okay this
is not your typical bong-bong-bong this
is yeah I'm like oh I like you now
that's what half of would be in Ariana's
bow so it became you'll say I hate love
relationship as I hate and then love and
then a little old trusty sidekick down
there yeah that ending hits hard man
definitely yes and it comes with barrier
rounds yes
very important oh yeah have you tried
you I don't know if you have if you're
high enough yet if you tried at nine
twenty now 20 but I I've heard the story
shout the Sinister yeah I've been told
what to expect and I better equip those
barrier mods and some of the stuff I got
please don't go into a 920 without fit I
don't know if you actually I don't know
if you can't I think and you start up as
a team like I don't know cuz you get
match-made at 9:29 50 you won't but nine
twenty year match made and my buddy and
I each made sure we had one of them
covered but one of mine was on like a
submachine gun and I'm trying to deal
with like an overload Minotaur that's
rough Rafa what's up Knapp fine how you
doing what's up guys yes the barrier the
barrier is part of the hardest to let in
the overload that's actually not so bad
it's hard to kind of deal with them a
range but if they get in range there
overload and basically you shoot them
and you stagger them and they kind of
stay like staggered and twitchy for a
little while and then if you just keep
dumping damage into them mmm and you
can't wait for meeeeee to get back up
and like a submachine gun hits them
enough pretty quickly where you snag him
back down so those were a little more
manageable with like you doing that and
then one other person but dude the
barrier mm-hmm one of my buddies had
like barrier on maybe an auto rifle or
something like that he put it on there
and he'd shoot it he might have been a
little low when we were going in but he
was still breaking down the shield and
do it and then that barrier shield would
come back up you can't take that barrier
shield down without it you literally
can't it is required so Ariana's isn't
barrier has the barrier realms in it so
you can actually bring that thing so
it's one of those that comes with it but
yeah the unstoppable over
and then the barrier barrier seems like
it almost is probably gonna be the
hardest
yeah and nowadays you telling me I mean
really gives that much more value to the
- Ariana's vowel you know it really that
kind of stuff is important man I mean
yeah it's great stuff well we had the
negative x I got I got some I got a
positive and I got a negative I'm ready
to rock
take one after you though you get no but
let's do it let's do it another positive
though yep yo solo crucible glory I
haven't touched that yet I'm waiting
long how is it just the fact that it
exists actually is a great man it's felt
fair you know I'm saying like I'll just
like okay I knew something was up when
I'm carrying the team cuz I'm not that
good like oh okay your boy is okay he's
above average I have my moments walk you
know I'll dominate and I my moments like
hey guys don't be the backpack I'm not
gonna I'm not trying not to get shot
mess up Katie yeah I'm definitely rough
times yeah I kind of go with the flow
but you know what's cool is again it was
no no break was in lockdown and one
would you have to you know to plant the
bomb we know all that
none of that oh yeah oh yeah no the comp
is now all survival survival three two
matches go fast you know what I'm saying
and um yeah I'm playing with a no I got
a I got a boy got to give myself a pat
on the back oh yeah
I carry how like a twenty four piece
after the match guys was like you got me
don't got me right just like I don't
have a backpack I got like cargo pockets
over here I don't have a full backpack
like not not yet yeah it felt good I'll
be just to you know have everyone you
know playing together Oh ultimate beer
no no no rest in peace trials we're not
gonna have that language here because I
played
showdown I've been played a lot of
crucible a place showdown and I'm
telling y'all right now date they
cooking they just trying to do different
variable because literally elimination
you mean that's eliminating celebs
yeah but the crucible labs but they also
have you tried to showdown mode
is separate that's been around I never
played this was that's bells in the labs
it was in labs it was in yeah they've
had it through yeah okay so this made it
to the prom time I must have when it was
last I mean it wasn't the rotators I
don't think anybody really loved it but
I never seen it yeah I remember it
coming through yep really okay so anyway
for whatever reason I missed it it was
okay you know I'm saying I mean at the
end of the day back to Elphaba's days
our comment is that that's what the labs
are gonna be there playing around with
on what elimination it's only a matter
of time they're just tweaking that's all
they're doing it tweaking tweaking
tweaking until the community comes up
with a consensus and what they think is
fair and it's happening there's no doubt
but as of right now you know comp I came
in there my trusty juju feeling good you
know do my thing felt good soloqueue
felt good shout the Bungie ban hammers
was in effect early that didn't take
long
couple days early so that that's what I
got on that man so shout out sit up so
you're up nice well you have a negative
to some curious yours take that one
it'll come back I played a little bit of
crucible
mhm it feels sweaty er than I expected
I'll be honest basically all crucible
feel sweaty and I'm going where all my
blueberries were although we're all the
new people aren't shoot where are they
seriously because I jumped in it was
like I mean I had some trash games I had
a couple that wouldn't okay but I had
that was like man where did all this
come from and I just want an even coming
back I don't know but not being crucible
I played Twilight gap was like literally
the first map I played laid widow's
quarter I haven't gotten it yet I play
both widows court him at I haven't seen
the new map fragment I haven't seen that
one yet played it I played a how was
that I feel forever um it's kind of it
reminds me there was a destiny one map
it reminds me of I thought it had that
like opening center where you could kind
of come up because I remember one like
that when I saw the picture I was like
is it
is it it's like a variation of that okay
it's almost like a variation of it you
know that map we're talking l can't
remember the name of it and I believe
what planet are we gonna say that is
that's um well then it like Kurt like
probably black garden ish is what I
garden is yeah but um yeah man it was
pretty good but yeah so you got a chance
to perhaps I mean either read the the
classics that's why light yeah so I look
up and it'll warm up I mean I probably
have like one or two good Snipes so what
I usually always could get a decent
snipe on is from the Cathedral looking
where kind of that little curved corner
is and it's it now they're just somebody
peak side and it's like yes yeah those
were always pretty good but no trust me
I got smoked many times and that cuz I
was like I had a bounty where I needed
Auto rifle kills I'm like these are the
wrong map so I'm trying to do both
rifles are still killing it pulls
friends were absolutely silly so I go
figure that's still there so we're gonna
be fine Oh
jiù jiù zài beast and bee sting it was I
was like mom I told you 24 off the RIP
I'm like now okay I remember my negative
okay but yeah I was like I mean it just
felt kind of it felt good to be back in
those maps those were about the few that
I played on I think so a little bit of
everything but overall felt good being
back it was cool like just a couple of
the nostalgia pieces that I've had so
far I've been and that was another one
just seeing those two maps I was like
yep these are classics I'm jealous I get
a chance to do it yeah what's your neck
what's your negative alright y'all again
it's early this is not enough thorough
testing so disclaimer disclaimer but um
scouts I need you I to come to the front
of the congregation I'm not feeling it
I'm not feeling it yet not again not a
lot of scouts I've tested so let's be
fair to Bungie yeah I'm saying but the
one that I had my heart set on is
complete trash to me which was oxygen
oxygen yeah I have my dragonflies speck
on it
I'm ready view it now infuse it or was
that in PvP no I put it in on I put it
in PvE I was trying to a couple of night
now in what the level was up as I'm
saying did you infuse it is rocking and
it's just it's I'm like I'm Pat and I'm
like it just didn't feel good man it
didn't feel strong now granted it may be
the barriers and stuff I did I pulled it
out on a nightmare or mission or
whatever nightmare hunt or whatever yeah
and I guess the nightmare guys had the
shields or whatever okay cool Photoshop
that Dan oh he said the blue scout for
you was the bomb try the game okay I'll
try different ones but right now oxygen
is in the bushes I really had my heart
set on oxygen I thought I had some
special medication by myself but I was
like oh it's going no it's not the one
no soul mm-hmm no oxygen right now so
until I have it I'll try it in PvP oh
this has been PvE exclusive testing you
know yeah so but you you guys cuz I got
more medicine tough uh I mean for me I
honestly like for me I'll probably go
negative
just as for kind of the rewards rewards
the old stuff and this may be a larger
encompassing thing they hits a couple
things like vendor refresh when you're
go it's just it's said that that stuff
still hasn't been touched and it hurts
like Amanda what's good would have made
that holiday she's got a chaperon
waiting on me but that's about it
got a lot going on over there in the
ship central basic ships but I mean
you've also got like Deborah bouquet cuz
like you had everybody farm their
materials you'd go to him right now
Deborah McKay and I don't know if it's
because he's the flashpoint enough to
see he's the vendor that works but
Deborah will actually drop packages at
your level so if you're missing
something that's lower he'll give you
some of those little filler spots for
all those farm materials he eat a mod
hookup no key sometimes if you get lucky
maybe I just had a lucky run he was just
shy
me with my oh yeah that's probably a
little luck but yeah it's just like you
have so many planets now we have vendors
on all of them that mostly of static
roles the old armor while it is armor
2.0 that's nice but all the weapons are
static and they're old like they have
been updated with new perks they don't
have nothing they don't have the option
for random roles either perks or random
roles or et like either or both just
like I don't know if there's one dude in
the corner I'm gonna get there said
haven't got there that's actually a good
one got to get a positive before you are
so hold that hittin that but yeah it's
just like it was going through and be
like I was turned in some packages it
never I'm gonna be like oh wait can I
get and I'm like got another scathing
lock same thing it's been for anything
over two years now right so I mean not a
whole lot change in there
I don't know that know like the
repeatable bounty is absolutely amazing
like that is a really really huge
addition because if you just want to go
grind out strikes like go do four or
five go back out grinder bounties head
back in and it's your way to continually
get gear but it's like what you get from
them unfortunately is not the best
so yeah the the vendors the vendors need
some love I've seen that out on Twitter
quite a bit yeah yeah
absolute ultimate bear see you heading
off bro
yeah the refresh yeah I was definitely
lovely surprised I was I would say that
I didn't I didn't think we would be in
that kind of a state again still which
is a surprising um yeah I said what meta
I was kind of like I said mess with
different archetypes and stuff like that
um I actually got a handout on some SMGs
and you're gonna like surprisingly I've
been using uh some G's like mad yo oh
yeah
daaad hundreds of smiles messing with
those two and you were kind of all right
on your PvP it was like I was it was
just like I got a nine thirteen one of
them to drop and it's like an energy so
I don't remember the name no but yeah
it's a sidearm and I'm just like going
through and I'm like hitting bullets
with my submachine gun but bando sidearm
bullets they hit I don't think it's
gonna like overtake my met up yet but if
it's like passing through my leveling
it's like I'll work with you mm-hmm
submachine guns though I've had those
coming through those are just puttin
constant work
I've been rotating those through and
you're gonna want either an auto or a
submachine gun for two of those
different types of mods so you're gonna
need to find some of those that you love
yeah absolutely just ripping through you
know damage and the DPS is pretty fast
definitely definitely felt good
definitely mmm-hmm
so said Fred so before we got to shadow
keep launch I recorded all of the public
events that are out there so it's like
no you don't want to make sure everybody
knows how to turn these into heroic some
do some don't new or whatever but it was
like I'm gonna wait till shadow cube
comes out because I want to add whatever
new public event they're made for the
moon so I could have it in there there
are no new public events it is still for
the walkers the war set and the high
virtual that's due to it's not it's it's
on Mars yeah you're right you're right
yes I trust me I know yeah feelings
thoughts I wanted one more new one come
on
like I don't know if there's some light
if there's gonna be an escalation
protocol level thing that happens out
later on in sorrows Harbor that we
haven't seen maybe there will cuz I
thought I saw an image of that
mm-hm but I was really hoping for some
type of new public event just to mm-hmm
just cuz I think somebody was playing
with or somebody in chat was saying the
same thing and they were like oh I saw a
public event coming being like oh I
wonder how we're gonna have to do this
one and the level horse that lands or a
big tank gets dropped and you're just
like oh I know how to do this one what
about the way know what that's a what's
that you're right
the was that it comes in in the which is
you gotta get wait
you got that yeah you've got the hive
ritual in the Hellmouth that's one yes
but yeah all of them are you can have
the ether resupply with the big servitor
you can have that one an archers line
but there are no new ones I mean there's
five I think there's quite a few
different ones on the moon but there are
no new ones on the moon right yeah yeah
I was surprised I didn't I didn't expect
that I thought we would get you know one
so it is what it is but um yes I would
say we started off pretty negative we
said I mean I've had a blast but I'm
like yeah picking stuff apart like low
exotic count yeah for a big season
launch actually it feels like at least
cuz worried about a few all of them seem
to come requests mmm
have you got the new rocket no I have
not but I've seen my boys got it yeah do
you have it yes what is your feeling on
it uh it's cool it's fun it's pretty
hard actually you'll see like it hit a
boss and if multiple of those little
void bombs hit its chunks coming off
right now it does take skill to use it
doesn't make the right size of room and
location to use to an extent because the
idea is it's a pretty good boost in
damage to you shoot it up and then it
kind of spreads in kind of an umbrella
and then it falls and that kind of
tracks towards what's around so it's
like trying to figure out your timing
because if you're going a little farther
smashes into a wall it's basically
wasted base days so basically it is
there is some skill to shooting it
it's a napalm Cataclysm Nova ball so
basically just got to shoot it up and
then it comes down and it spritz it in
it rains yeah yeah it rains little
tracking ones they won't track like
forever but if you're in the kind of the
right radius you'll catch them yeah it
looks amazing like when you see that
thing in your inventory it's it looks
really really cool the quest is quest is
pretty lengthy there's definitely some
parts to it which you're cool it's one
of your first memories that you deal
with with her so I'm wondering there's
like if there's more of those if
like me or how many of those are gonna
be through and then the 9:20 mission to
do it is a throwback to a kind of a raid
encounter which is kind of fun
so like that quest was cool that's like
that was a legit exotic quest so I
concurred the quest it had cooled like
multiple steps to it the final fight was
legit hard like I'm gonna end up helping
multiple people with that one I mean I
saw it the first time but it's fine I
think it was weird though on that one I
soloed it and it did not feel didn't
feel overly like I'm trying to think
like spongy or anything else felt it
felt about right I was like I was 13
below there was a challenge that guy was
taking damage I was trying to stay
mobile but it felt doable and then I
played that with a buddy of mine it was
just he and I I helped him with it after
and it felt about that way but then I
had a fireteam of three I like it was
something one more person and my buddy
was with me that one felt noticeably
harder so I don't know there was like a
scaling there that happened with a full
fireteam or something but or if it was
just maybe I was running out of heavy or
whatever it was but that time things too
felt longer to kill so I don't know if
there was a scaling that happened there
not sure don't ever test that that often
but Solo wasn't too shabby and if you
are about level ready for at nine
fifteen nine twenty by the time you get
there I did it like 907 it was still
doable so we still get out the black
wait he's got some good points he says
he's feeling the invasions may take the
place of the new public event which is
true we still haven't seen invasions
maryland's we still have things because
obviously you see the indicators on the
map for where you know there's three of
them that just like kind of quietly like
pulsing right now there's this wavy you
know waiting for Saturday so yeah you
know say and then I have to give him the
second point Lisa Lowe exotics but hi
catalyst drops I have been seeing the
catalyst drop and that dag i've been
refreshing to see which ones which ones
you got Cerberus Tenace Oh got haze yeah
it dropped on one of my couple crucible
that dropped in one of my first couple
crucible matches
Cerberus dropped like from a strike or
no from a public event something working
on that one so okay yeah I'll have to
test that one when I get it I mean
servers with auto rifles like ear if you
can get in because it's not I mean you
can't work it from range it's spread is
terrible but if you get in that close
range and you just pump it into say like
some of the nightmare acolytes cuz those
things have a chunk of health and you're
yeah but you can work them down with
that thing actually pretty just like a
clip on something that's usually taking
a lot of work to kill it's putting in
some work from that closer range so if
you can get some of those guys that
aren't as lethal and you need to pump
some damage in it's good it's gonna put
in some work cuz that auto boost is
getting a feel so okay well speaking of
damage oh yeah is Nagi touch that yet oh
oh it's dirty oh and you just take it
you're just ripping chunks off people
you know that is like now my damn I wish
we had you know the older uh well with
the old Luda facts are just all I'm sure
oh man it would it's just it's real
peace I just got to find something to
pair it in the energy cuz I'm just don't
my my little strategy I thought of um my
kindred orchid that nerfs to rampage and
you know kill clip a little bit and it
has been arranged just that was the me
that gun that feel good so now I'm like
I might need to rock a auto or SMG in
that energy
cuz I need something to go with izanagi
you know I'm saying when they are up
close but is it Nami but I'm seeing
people use it in crucible crucible
somebody who's on my team reckon with it
I'm like alright so yeah if you guys got
in tsunami now's the time man this thing
is you know it may not be fast DPS but
you're gonna be putting in chunks you
ripping chunks out of people thanks
serious mm-hmm
yeah so how's the Harahan cants feel
overall for you just in general again
the only one really that has the rave
review cuz I haven't played a lot with
them to be honest which was Ariana but
the other one like I said the Kindle
didn't feel well I think that's a one
I'm gonna say that's a 150 yeah that's
as good as mine and it's someone that I
think if I tell you right now it's yeah
it's one of those
you feel - too hot boy okay yeah plaid
with loud bullabbai I think that's a 110
so kind of like Duke
that's the new one from the moon I
played it that was like just what was in
my inventory for the crucible matches it
was hitting pretty hard it was like two
to three taps so something like that it
was yeah not bad in the range was about
where it felt but for me hand cannons
hand Kansas always felt like they've
hitting too hard to from too far so
bright I know some people and I may get
shot for this one but some people may
just like hate it but it's like if hand
cannons don't hit from as far away I
still was getting hit by some and I was
like but yeah like they're not gonna
like half map you with ace or something
like that with right as it should be I
mean ace is still probably good but yeah
I think hand cannons probably are a
little better where they should be and
they give him true Vanguard is saying
it's like I'm probably gonna get some
flack for this but it's like I think
that's I think this needed to happen so
I think I need to happen I mean they
need a place to play and they were a
little too far now the only thing I want
to shout out asked across he's got a
good point
I agree overall what you said I agree
with Bangor I think the hand cane and
range drop wolf was correct that was the
correct hole but who got affected in
there in the crossfire was Crimson cuz
crow I didn't realize how to cast across
he got a great video out and um yeah
Cruz he got hurt it didn't get the buffs
did not did the drop off is so bad with
it and it they still statistically
supposed to be the longest range one
yeah it's a pulse and it's not really
the you know so yeah it didn't it is not
it's actually worse than what it was he
did the number you did this so I was
actually surprised by that that one got
hit hard because it got it fell under
the blanket nerve yeah you said I'm
saying whereas you know if they maybe
should have been able to do something
with it kind of like how they did with
risk of lumber I'm gonna risk runner
with um huckleberry yeah uncle Barry
kind of broke free from the the nerves
of arm you know rampage and all that
other stuff so that's that I will say on
a side note um Frederic's
in PvE yo oh yeah yo see I haven't been
in musings I've just been playing with
I got yo cuz I got one to drop from Saks
another would be nice yo beef use
beguile roll one with this one man yeah
yeah it hits like a truck when you get
desperado melting that's so fast
yes yeah it's crazy shout out to people
yeah I'm hearing I'm hearing Cerberus
Katya I'm hearing Cerberus is real
serious because I haven't got a chance
to pull that out
Cerberus something real good things but
um yeah if you guys got rhetorics man
PvE especially PvP was rules okay you
gonna say I'm gonna say his bad still
kicks a little bit but um yeah PvE
yeah I was super impressed more so I
mean breakneck is my baby blood yes I
mean rhetorics is right up there now
very cool mm-hmm
trying to make for me on weapons and
stuff that I've been using servers using
anything no I mean I haven't I haven't
infused man I've literally been using
whatever is past well character so I've
been there's been blue autos there was a
pulse that felt good for a little bit
and there been blues just literally
everything I did was impulses still feel
mostly okay mm-hmm so my go figures
though you need some infusion at some
point maybe for Saturday morning or
something like that
or chicken red Rick's making it - I
don't know so bro I pull out I'm telling
y'all right now if you may need a little
counterbalance or whatever you just it
does kick a little bit so if you got
stability stats you know definitely rank
them up but I'm first well even without
desperado it's hitting hard no you throw
desperat yo I was laughing at yellow bar
so it's just so fast and then you just
keep the train going like it's create
another one get another precision kill
click hit outlaw keep the flow going
you're melty it almost felt like a hard
hitting from distance breakneck and
y'all know how I like breakneck yeah
braking that's my baby
you're on same as Auto but your reg
Rick's bro I'm telling you continue I've
been using a decent amount of art I've
been using D cement of the moon weapon
so I got the new
mood machine gun which is it Sark I'm
trying to remember the speed its arc
it's nice yeah it's a nice it's a nice
balance of like not quite delirium
insanity but not like the slower it's
it's a good mid-range one I'm actually
kind of digging that one arc logic like
the auto rifle and PvP doesn't do auto
rifles in PvP like man I just feel like
I'm I'm wounded people but I can't
finish it all I'm doing I can't it
doesn't matter like they only need three
shots to hit and I'm trying to hit like
12 and I just can't get them all to
connect in time between there 1 2 3 hand
cannon shots at him now so yeah pvp cuz
I was there was a bounty was working I'm
like I should need auto kills come on
it's just like breaking my head against
this auto rifle I didn't have it so
mm-hmm now the auto rifles for me in PvP
they're not bad like PvP or PvE they're
not bad auto rifles just like mowing
down ads and stuff like that pump it out
bullets they're actually pretty decent
but in PvP just I was the one I had
wasn't feelin right so maybe just the
crowd also yeah I haven't seen our
Monty's good I've had it clutch day yeah
yeah our Monty's are really good there's
some things I want to ski with there's
been some funny builds and I've seen was
it glad did some like shoulder charge
and one shoulder charge with Paragon
Greaves and picked up like the nightmare
buff at the same time on a lost sector
boss on the servitor and just like one
Needham stop it's just literally smashed
him clean so I don't even have paragon
grooves yep I didn't get him last season
so says a good misfit actually misfit I
remembered I got yeah but it was good
yeah I've been trying well it's been a
while some that one's coming through
what else yeah but I mean Tranquility
used it a little bit but it like just
some of those I'd get them and then they
can get over leveled so I've really just
been here I've literally been using
everything that's come through some
grenade launchers I still I still
honestly after grenade launchers Rockets
just for the ammo you have never hold up
in my opinion Rockets don't agree
whether it's cluster with it's just like
it's one shot because I wouldn't with a
rocket yeah you could shoot the ground
but then you're gonna have most of
same effect was a grenade launcher and
then I'm gonna have 18 more rounds as
opposed to six so it's funny you say
that because I kind of like it though I
mean rockets must be real like rockets
have dominated metas in destiny for a
long time no turn yellow horns and no
roots and galleys I mean that's been the
thing for years so it's like I kind of
like grenade launchers like how to be
aware the end yeah I got a random roll
on one - I got a doomsday with full
court rangefinder spike grenades mm-hmm
late yeah so it hits pretty hard that
was just and that was like doomsday from
the stuff I was doing I didn't I haven't
touched reckoning have not touched game
a prime and somehow I got somehow I got
a doomsday I don't know where it popped
through I don't actually remember yeah
okay okay interesting shout-out to Aaron
kilo rifles have the best feedback
between inflicting damage as a
reasonable fire rate I can't put my eat
the doctor down for long but in PvP each
missed bullet hurt yeah that sounds
about right actually that's not right
yeah at this how I feel about it's the
same way you know with um what you were
saying about you know you're okay with
hanging can't I'm kind of okay let's do
this how I look at our rivals not to see
you get to it's kind of a big ears
weapon like it's just point shoot go
right point you go so I feel that not
that it shouldn't be rewarded but I feel
something that requires a little bit of
a lot more skill when aiming should have
a little bit more lethality than it but
I like it that it's still in a place
that it can play but it's just not in a
place where it can dominate it's not in
a place where you're gonna you know be
ripping up a lot of people that's the
bidding yeah I was gonna say I can to
tap somebody with my go figure
yeah to trigger pull and they're done
that auto rifle will never compete with
even if I hit every shot embrace your
whole stole like you should it's a it's
a three burst right is it 2:01 two holes
recive frame super beasty don't you got
the the guys
go figure but yes if that doesn't change
the damage though it's still if I hit
eight headshots you're done I cannot get
the bullets out fast enough on my old a
rifle to match you but I would say from
ranges I'm gonna use numbers like this
okay like I'm just gonna use their
failure numbers all right from range 0
to 1
you're not beating the auto rifle here
now range I would say like one two and
out yeah they're all of my friend got a
shot that's that's how I look at it you
know I'm saying now I hate what you say
maybe they should be a little bit more
like tally up close but then they're in
a tough spot because they got auto
rifles there here's what Roberts gotta
compete with you guys everything
basically yeah assume she's got to do
something sidearms got to do something
so I don't mind that all rifles catch it
a little bit on that lesser damage
because I'm let's be honest it's
literally here you are bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang till you're
dead hold the button bang bang bang like
it's not a skill weapon y'all act like
all rifles deserve this levels from you
oh my god this is news no I did notice
on the rifle hatred yeah like I want my
hand cannon to be a three shot only you
must land all headshots and be elites it
must be elite only exactly how you sound
yes get that Simple Simon Auto rifle
better out of here like listen unless
it's exotic you know give me like mom
what's the mati if suros got buffed I'm
all for the exotic auto doing some work
but if you come in there with you know
you know eat the doctor or whatever
these models are but as like said France
and you're saying it's like they live in
the range of shotguns and fusions and
SMGs and there's like even with recluse
in there - it's like recluse already is
gonna melt you so fast and there's and
the auto-rifle can't live in a range
that it's gonna like it has to be
farther away to try and compete and stay
away from those or then if you're far
enough away for those not to be a matter
you may as well just use a pulse I hate
you know orals I agree
it's just news to me I did not know this
year we never had this discussion yeah
yeah auto-life we should be rewarded
I've never felt I've always felt pulses
are at hand cannon and are more of a
skill based weapon so if you listen if
I'm aiming at you you move I missed a
head shot I'm in trouble you know I'm
saying whereas the auto you know you
just literally pressing in is my list
and I look at it but I do agree with you
guys it's like there's not that easy
though then why aren't you out there
just using that Oh easy mode Auto rifle
just point and shoot at that mid range
it shouldn't be rewarded with that level
of damage to be in the matter
you did that in basic level we just
literally said it doesn't have a place
though they should they got nine weapons
in one my fault like looking they want
to keep you think that auto rifle should
be bumped up a smidge because alright
let me ask you okay if if they get
bumped up a smidge will use SMG who
gonna use they got a big got to keep him
there yes so faster time to kill at the
range that it's meant to be I would
never like that before
smg's were not really like just recently
with the recluse and SMGs is finally in
that spot like y'all we hear y'all
better watch out and Rekluse is just
ridiculous let's just call that what it
yes Raguse is is kind of skewing this
list because if we take recluse out
who's really using oh I try to normal
SMG else getting worked
yeah work so it's recluse for don't be
blaming my assumes no as far as side I'm
you know damn well chat ain't none of
y'all pulling out that James Bond
bangbang foolishness
instead go watch yeah yeah I know I'm
telling the truth with me they don't
chat I want to hear the last time y'all
pulled out that P Walter it's no one's
doing no but it's just like the
consistency of like the bullets of by
Auto rifle I'm gonna it feels really
like a really tight grouping is what it
should be but I'm missing just enough
shots like that at that small range
where that hand cannon which I'm sorry
hand cannon auto rifle
are we gonna go now we go this is a new
laughs but I didn't know about this no
but no revolver okay take fine take what
like take current time not sci-fi okay
no I'm just saying picture in your mind
a revolver which you'd picture a hand
cannon like a big-ass 357 Magnum fine
okay that's fine how accurate from range
do you think that's gonna be how far
away do you think you can be accurate
versus and then we're gonna be
reasonable
just like I mean even an ak-47 is a bad
example but yes yes like those two
should not compete at the ranges that
the ak-47 should not be dealing with
that revolver because that revolver is
not accurate from that range so hey Mike
you may come up wait- I'm saying hand
cannons should not be competing with
auto rifles but they do so you feel auto
rifles [ __ ] out dual hand cannons is
that what we do in a fourth at a range
where they're at a range that makes
sense
okay so let's use fictional numbers so
let's say this is zero right on top of a
guardian one couple of places and then
it's the two range where should all the
rifles be beating more than just two
ranges for your looking and segments
rear rage 3 okay so like a pole second
like half map somebody look if I'm
trying to do the same thing where I'm
like half mapping somebody pretty
solidly with my go figure that auto
rifles like missing like half my shots
okay so that's like the more accuracy
you want more accuracy with more Ange
I want more accuracy from range because
if you get cliff you creep in closer
that hand cannon now free taps you which
I got it I got the auto for you oh yes
sorceress regime baby I know sir I did
still missus pulled it out really yes
yes
Soros PU you plan was spinning up don't
spin it up as beast I hope you're not
using the focus fire while you spin and
up that is very least anyone anyway we
won't finish this right god no you're
not pulling out a sidearm and wiping to
you
Larry listen go to katrell new Caesar
Ducati go and leave listen brother did
not know about this elitism overall
rifles they're late okay this is your
new challenge go take that auto rifle
and go mop the floor go go show and see
where you find a good spot for it listen
I'm not gonna say it act like I'm
running around you just totally didn't
hear anything you just said
I said now like I'm running around with
rifles the whole day right but like I
said the ones that I've tried that I've
had a been effectively is misfit someone
put out in the chat misfit I was
beasting with the ringing nail the one
from armed black armory I believe these
are like 600 right the 600 I've been
having a good time for 50s I agree for
50s feel garbage in PvP do not bring a
450 I'm with you it feels like you're
gonna lose it doesn't finish try the six
hundreds I would say and um see as far
as the exotics but yeah guys you gotta
get soros is B's bro if you at least
from range what it can compete they can
compete it's not that ism you're as
funny you say you're real Noah yeah I
mean like decent but just without the
new mods it's still you know weapon 1.0
you know I can't even mess with any of
those things without any of those mods
so but I will I'll give some more autos
this shot in PvP and I will report back
I'm just curious from the elitist over
here so yeah it's not a skill weapon it
should not be rewarded I'm stand-in or
network anyway that was a long tangent
but you guys know those are always gonna
happen
what else for you
he got up she got downs how things how
we have we'll get to the spoiler stuff
later we're still saving that little
opinion in that part of the episode to
the end what about you what do you been
what you've been digging on ups downs
and gets left Babs writes she's been
having fun man I just been um I just
love that the 900 the soft cap level
was very relaxed to me it's very yes I
felt like you know what I thought I was
gonna have to stress it was like nah man
just I was doing more public events I
was just running around and then normal
for world drops or beneficial that's new
that's new and it felt it felt good you
know I'm saying felt good to be able to
to do that kind of stuff and um just in
general matches it's good to see
everybody back playing destiny like that
just overall like just seeing the
community you know won't get together
and old faces you haven't seen and
people like y'all linking up we'd do it
I was in parties of like you know
everyday between six to eight you know
of different clan members and just
everyone's just having a ball and
putting the pics up
it's been good man it's just again when
destiny is good this it's very hard to
beat this game and it's really hard to
be now I'm again the jury is out or
shadow keep it's early we're in the
honeymoon phase
we gotta see how this rate gonna be
we're gonna talk about campaign spoilers
we do all that stuff but all it just it
just it just feels good man and like we
said that nostalgia everything man it
just it just really really feels good so
that's been my overall positive with it
you know I'm saying yeah I agree I'm in
the 750 to 900 honestly didn't know what
to expect when it came to infusion the
time it would take to get up there
things like that I mean yeah people for
a new player especially if you don't go
abuse tokens if you don't go because
planetary material stuff like that that
will be smooth which is the nice thing
just playing and stuff like that they
save the milestones they save the prime
engines all of those things to get 900
but 900 is a bit of a little bit of a
gut punch man that is a slowdown you
feel like you just like you jog and
smooth you're starting to pick up some
speed you get in there oh god hold on
what did I hit like it is it is a hard
like whoa pull back on those reins buddy
we are gonna slow way down down - oh
yeah first gear going through that
school zone just going real slow oh yeah
yeah cuz yeah now it's just like where
can where can I get now you're just like
where's that gear where can I get the is
that mean you guys got any more of that
level up it's like nope it is out it is
gone yeah the grams are a lot harder to
come by so those yeah
now the power bonus from the artifact
school slows down a little bit but it's
definitely been beneficial if you play
for a reasonable amount of time but I
will say like that the wall of the
powerful ziz is real it's real it's real
cuz I just said you hit now hundred you
got you get into that that feel of
things are ascending fast it's like you
said it's like literally say someone
says okay that's it now yeah now we're
playing for you you enjoyed your fun
exactly now we're in the man's game and
you've got a it basically becomes a
thinking man's game right okay
what's the more efficient way to do
things what not to do like do not do
your powerful drops I'm telling people
all the new life people they have you do
not do any of that powerful stuff until
you get to nine hundred resist the
temptation and you know I am yeah I am
knows history Clee the worst when it
comes to wasting materials infusing when
I shouldn't and I have been like a saint
I've been staying away from that stuff
somehow yeah you be bro you be proud my
materials is high everything is highest
and I'm like yo descrying
past 900 it's a good thing I was sick
like this thing is real all right you've
got to be strategic per you don't per
really I look at your guardian as a
whole and and really look at where
you're low at and what you need to work
on that the timing of when you do things
there is a lot to it to be efficient
otherwise you know you can hit some
walls you know I'm saying and it's real
it's real man yeah it's it's been yeah
it was fun of 11:3 just playing here be
like all this a little bit more all this
a little more but I will say in fairness
to Bungie the news like zero to three
drops the ones that help you below one
that might drop at your level that one
nice is a little lagging behind now you
got this one a little higher and even if
it's just like one those little ones
make that part feel
because whatever I was doing on like my
warlock my second character and mm-hmm I
was like your uh huh meet your ah
humming through the car you're fine the
more you do the more you talk I'm all
right here Shafi yeah but yeah it's like
it's kind of it's still it's a wall for
sure but there's a little in there it
eases it out a little bit because it was
his rough up until you start getting a
feel for how the powerful works and then
there's like so right now we have Tier
one which seems to be like plus three
more powerful gear drops that's pretty
consistent tier two is plus four and the
only I'm curious your thoughts on this
one the only two places for tier two are
playing exp which you kind of wonder how
a new light player may not even know
about that for a little while and then
gambit three matches of gambit is your
other tier two they're steering people
to something yes
somebody's engagement numbers but can
you just put that little higher reward
over there we need some people in their
place exactly yeah man I'll be shad the
dramatic man glad you made it better
yeah the Topix yeah it's very
interesting the selections they've
they've made for powerful where there's
good this theory what I will say is this
though I do like that crucible had
different areas of play yeah I did like
that wasn't just like oh five crucible
matches I was like huh as it cuz we play
PvP god I'm like see this is the love
the balance that I need pvp to be have
shown sometimes late matches worth of
stuff in there so too powerful that was
nice you know I'm saying like go you
know I'm saying so that right there was
cool but yeah it's very interesting to
me because of how they've limited
powerful drops kind of you know
planet-wide
right like it's it's not money not
running loose out here like how it used
to be so yeah it is interested in their
steering in gambit very very interest
and then there's the suppose that glitch
that's why I haven't done it Vanguard
strikes first the nightfall ordeal if
you do the Vanguard strike powerful drop
potentially the nightfall drop
isn't powerful and vice-versa so only
we'll only do one of the Vanguard's you
may as well put your time into the
strikes because the nightfall may not
actually benefit you right now I think
I've heard it's glitched really yep
so yeah you can do three strikes or if
you do nightfall the nightfall says zero
of five but if you even do a hero
difficulty nightfall that counts for two
so the difficulty will speed through
that later on but right now yeah just do
your three night three Vanguard strikes
and get your powerful there it's just
easier than putting your time into
trying to do the nightfall cuz that's
not potentially worth it I hear at the
nose you told me that I'm gonna do the
Shrike oh one last thing that I've got
crucible yo beneficial and again I love
flake yeah well sample size no I like
first of all I've been getting like also
you didn't you know I'll be getting like
three to four drop sometimes
exotics no snow
yes don't was playing crucible he was
like dude I'm just over here good like
five drops a match get like levels and
stuff like this just like blues slaps
one on raining down man rain and let's
go reward us for playing this mode that
you're not showing the most love to like
let's go like that that felt good man I
got a ton less though in there I got
some pro I got like crazy stuff inside
the crucible I'm just like what is going
on like I almost feel like I was
cheating like I was getting away with LA
I mean dude get in here get this done
before they find out what I'm different
but yeah a crucible reward wise is
beneficial for leveling I could not be
even the Blues in we're helping the low
one or two here you know I'm saying and
then um I was noticing um I will ask you
this though what do you do you have
anything early right now that you can
say is a good mod source cuz I really
want my it's like that's what's killing
me right now
oh yeah mostly packages Vanguard tokens
crucible tokens if you got those turning
those in like I was using those to get
armor because there's like leveling up
second and third characters and if you
have those like every other package or
something like that I was getting a nice
and mount so I've unlocked some
obviously not all but yeah they're
coming from packages a lot for me ever
soft and it's like a random chest I'll
get one but mostly a lot have been those
package turnings for me okay
that's where a lot of the mods have been
coming from I was trying to see if there
was any way and I was wondering if they
were like hiding specific because I know
like there's like when you do the
nightmare hunt their specific mods that
only seemed that they don't seem like
they only drop there I don't know which
oh well yeah the nightmare hunts have
like nightmare mods so yeah that's year
I've had because you get the dream main
with the set and then I've got two other
nightmare mods so far um that'll help
with certain things so that's been like
grenades do more damage to nightmares or
something else that I've seen and say oh
there's a couple specific ones there
mm-hmm but go in that seasonal slot
yeah I'm tempted also to do like an old
raid before the new one just to see like
how the drops go you know I'm saying as
far as arm armor and to see how that's
handled with Leviathan specific Tim
because I'll notices some armor I was
getting didn't have the dream bane stuff
and I'm saying you know a couple most of
them did so yeah it's it's interesting I
want to see um if they keep up that
pattern of certain armors have specific
extra mod slot for specific activity
because that's what I was noticing and
um I did level up the Solstice stuff um
didn't see anything extra specific oh
another question I have for you with
mods um shout to Kaiba's oh he did tell
me that the Paragon mod exists but I do
have an issue when you look at the stats
right we got the old stats in the new
and you know obviously with intellect
it's the super then you got the strength
with the melee but the thing that's
missing as a stat is the class there's
another class items tab because it's a
static just whatever charge that and it
is that's what they lifted it but
there's no way there's no quantity right
to the quantify to see what the number
is like for example there is a pair I
know there's a Paragon mah and I'm like
I would love to bring that down you know
what I'm saying and see where that is
because I'm working on a bill I gotta
build I'm working off at a raid it's
gonna be a bottom sheet stormcaller
and I'm thinking I'm gonna actually
witch
very effective was armed what's the old
Vesper of Radiesse know and it's like
might be all I kind of say this real
quick all right P well radiance didn't
feel good didn't feel good yeah I was
getting killed in it it just I don't
know why I didn't mess with the healing
supposedly right it just feels Oh No
maybe cuz I was using maybe dad that
nurse is what if I don't know it just
didn't feel like it was supposed to feel
but we'll see he didn't feel quite as
godly standing in your little circle of
wonder yeah I didn't feel like I was
controlling a circle okay just stand in
the open and take all the shots in the
world anymore what like use cover not
just open area BAM Neil through
everything damaged way dramatic agrees
me man yeah like know before you put
that like home oh you're like the
warlock makes an announce hold on you're
the world is coming you put the well
their party
nah now you getting killed in that well
right now bobble yeah that's about Titan
let's go put area on his Val in a well
of radians bubble that's a one shot in
PvP I was I think it was cool holla yep
cool guy did that yep yes yeah he's like
pops out Bam Bam I was like holy crap
that was like three rounds Ray's usual
PvP I was like you salute but I'll be a
well from a little little wee little
weird but you know I'm willing to give
it a shot but I don't think I'm well for
the rate man I don't think I'm going
well I mean I see yeah if you can do a
healing rift just functionally to help
out and then have that bubble for your
damage it's a bigger damage buff anyway
and you only get one buff and you get
one debuff so that's the other side of
it too yeah absolutely and I got that
that stone call exotic man it feels good
oh the new one yeah finish the campaign
here you go
strong but if that's like if that's our
three that's where I'm like that's not
great like if that's our only one so cuz
we've got ya we're getting a shortlist
this season so and this is where I
wonder it's like shadow keep is a big
launch they have so much on their plate
like was so much on the plate but some
things didn't quite get
there that's yeah I would have to agree
I would have to agree again but we still
we know we're gonna get some quest
exotics right shots at cops going by
they don't agree but uh what do you
think do you think how many more do you
think we gettin more what Sonic's uh I
mean she has the memories so I don't
know how many of those they're gonna be
or if it's just like a one-time thing
it's just at a weekly bounty which was
weird to kick that whole cycle off for
that
mm-hmm for the grenade launcher rocket
launcher that was one but that was
literally started at a weekly bounty
which was weird yes go through that or
what shout out to those lost sectors on
the moon by the way they're all awesome
yeah you haven't done any of them
haven't done one yet well by the way
they're 870 so if you trip into one of
those and be like hey we got any lost
sectors let me go in one shot just done
[Laughter]
oh yeah on the moon that 870 lost sector
first day just smacked me around real
quick I was like not going in here for a
while yeah that feels okay at about nine
hunt they feel how they they feel like
how Lost sectors should light there
they're deep there's multiple levels to
have the last one with the hive up north
and sorrows Harbor we got like mechanics
to the thing dude it's like yes legit up
there the losses on the moon the lost
sectors on the moon I do have to say
felt really good all of them it they
felt to agrees mmm did you yeah they're
yeah you'll get some time in them on the
exotic quest anyway but they're cool
they really are I like what they did
with them each one is each one has their
feel kind of Awesome they that's that's
how I'd like I don't know they just felt
better and I can't really put my finger
on why like one of them was a really
huge spacious cavern you're going
through air and they just I don't know
they just felt better than before
alright I got it it's funny lost sex
I've been multitasking and in my
pursuits and for some reason they just
escaped me I haven't done it is always I
got I got a jump in there man yeah
yet lost sectors are good what about
Sheila what about you yeah to me it's
just been all about build synergy you
know raid prep you know shout that if
he's on me you know he's trying to
construct a team yes I'm like alright
I'll be available I guess I'm just
trying to get the light up obviously I
know you still running you are you
you're used to running or what we go out
yeah I think I got a crew I gotta see
how my weekend did balancing my time and
all that stuff goes I mean I'd like to
see how it goes I mean if I bend my head
against the boss for like six hours I'm
not gonna stay in there like if we don't
give to the first encounter with contest
just crushing us or some reason then I'm
just gonna you know I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna put that much effort in for
the emblem but I'd like to do it in the
first ten days for it I want to track it
well the shirt can get all season but so
that'll happen at some point
Jackie properties the jackets ten days
the shirts all season I did not know the
jacket was available I did not read
correctly yeah the judge will be within
the first ten days
and then the Cena talked a lot of crap
with my dad Jackie O dramatics got a
good point like the nightmare Patrol
people yes oh my god there's too many of
them you're like I'm sorry what dude
calm well hold on you're freaking out
okay kill enemies I can do that yes mmm
it's like no there's too many and you're
like what is happening dude you're just
like this guys over here crouched under
the thing and you're like yeah alright
do you use a voice yes I love the use of
voice with controls it just being around
the moon that haunted feel more haunted
y'all is really haunted
yeah even my wife just was like asking
me it's like why is it a haunted on
Twitter all of that yes yeah yes like
and then I think scare Oh was scare SK
he did it too and my name can't do that
it was like sorry sorry
chosen ones brother
so yeah the jacket the ball I might
listen I'll try to get it done days late
case is enough time days is enough I
think days is enough
I'd like to because then you got the
full next weekend to go through yeah so
this weekend yeah it's got to be next
weekend for me because week after would
be I've got family coming in so yeah
yeah that weekend should be hopefully at
some point get a group sale all right I
know we've been beating around the bush
I know we haven't talked about it so
just think and this may open up some
other things too as well this is a
warning for the podcast
big big spoiler warning if you have not
played the campaign go play it if you
have not played shadow keep bought it
yet get out of here
so we're gonna wrap up basic wrap-up and
then we'll get into it so for me it's
easy he bought his twitch Twitter
YouTube sub follow like subscribe get
yourself in the giveaway for the stream
deck which is still going on for another
week all that stuff is going on I'm not
so no you're good that's a big siren out
there so we got big things happening so
but yeah I'm Yvonne - so everywhere you
guys can find me the support some great
watch me on Twitch watch the YouTube
videos thank you
we're gonna head in a spoiler key but
kognito has got to let you guys know
where to find him and we'll be coming so
yes boy lucky again shows not old boiler
boiler keep going down right I'm a
podcaster on YouTube and you know that's
where you can find me and Lords of
gaming dotnet for also your cool destiny
articles as well so we don't get into
the spoiler keep now let's gold man
that's gay where do you want to start
this one mission one I must start off
with a meal mentally let me build a deck
back here I will at you when we do it um
do the big waving hands well this is
spoilers if you're watching this is
spoilers if you see this again and you
want to fast-forward then we might be
done otherwise this will just be the
rest of it but if we finish out spoiler
stuff when we got more all big crazy
wave again dramatically you'll bring no
spoilers oh well we should I'm putting
it boilers done or something to chat so
yeah I can see it whatever just be
but um yeah man like for me I'll be real
with you
um eres stuff wasn't really wow I mean
him getting we started off and all I
would like cool cool you know she was
just into her nonsensical eres mode and
I'm just like okay
nonsense Clarence whatever spirits
haunting would have okay I wasn't really
okay this is just average right I just
wasn't nothing really it wasn't terrible
but just nothing really was Wow like
this is so crazy I was like okay I'm on
the mall we're gonna do something then
that moment happened and you know that
moment when you first go down in that
cave and you get in the fields away you
used to be and you see the space Dorito
oh my god chillin I lost my mind
openness the ghost freaking out and I
was like yo this is different ah so did
it we're doing this is what we've been
holding for file of years in the making
literally yes this feels like
progression you know saying we saw this
at the end of you know the red war
campaign when you beat Gaul yeah we saw
them pull up so we're like okay let's
see what's going on they turn the lights
on they're like what yeah
so dad for so yeah man so that mission
and just the way that played out set the
tone for me and again we talked about
music you know just it was just
tremendous just that whole par so that
that for me I'll just start there and
I'll let you continue you know swell
cast really got me excited and you tell
me what other moments or that moment
about that moment well no that was so
yeah you're going through the cave
you're like I'll we're open on the moon
okay we're going through okay we got
some tanks that's cool going through
clearing this thing going into the keep
going down there's the the shot first as
you're going down in the canyon you see
up into the moon you have a few of the
like
the guardian kind of risks up there and
you like what done but that shot to here
on the moon sorry the shot to earth
that's a legit shot that's a really well
liked director photography like just
looks awesome then when you you like you
go through the cavern and when you turn
and it's just I stopped I was just like
holy holy basically yeah holy holy crap
was like big big giant like pyramid
ships pastry dough's are joking but like
near big ship is in there and I was like
so what I had heard and this is why I
had heard a leak is that was what was
woken up now that's the leak I had heard
but even seeing it didn't matter so that
was the leak I had heard a while it goes
like she had woken it up this is what
starts it and then like but they say she
the rumors that she woke well or she
what I mean you saw her touch like the
ground and then that was a little
cinematic in the opening right in the
nightmare and then it like then it was
the you know sighs the geological
disturbance or whatever and that's when
the hive all came rushing in so that's
like what kind of kicked it off so
that's like a little bit that I had
heard somehow she may have been the
catalyst and like when investigating
something she shouldn't have right I
didn't walk it up but no dude the first
time I saw that ship I lost I just in my
mind I was like I was so excited that's
the future that that's d3 what we get
near and again matter of progression and
I will say this as much as I'm clowning
you know errors for her nonsensical
stuff sometimes for the first time I
felt empathetic for her yeah I'm like
Jake she's suffering you know say like
she's going through it and even a
quarter I she kind of intimates that
look you know we weren't real I wasn't
there for you you know I don't shouldn't
have been alone
I like their little dynamic it's kind of
interesting it but um yeah like I was
like yo I really have more of a pre cuz
to me she was just always just weird
just way off you know out there but this
DLC I feel it's building with her and
yeah man let's continue what else are
the story beats did you like yeah so I
mean after you see the space Torito and
then all of a sudden you
like what is this glowing little red
figure down here on the rocks and you
know what's got to happen at some point
you're just wondering where and then all
of a sudden out pops big blue glowy guy
you're like oh god it's chronic oh let's
go let's go
yeah that was fired and not only was it
crota it was gall and it was oh yeah you
got both of them right there in the
middle o3o usually I'm like I'm plated
none other playthroughs I don't know if
it just went faster but I only see two
if I don't see the third grow yeah
fanatics up there - yeah crazy and it
just it was just like oh my god we got
to get out of here like we cannot become
like it's crazy yeah yeah she got a she
hightailed it crazy sequence love that
visit yeah so I mean just the opening
seeing all those guys come back deal
with Kuroda then you're figuring about
the nightmare mechanics they introduced
you to with the thrall and the acolytes
and stuff so you can actually do damage
to him so like that's your introduction
to the nightmare get mechanic so you get
a feel for that BSC and courtesy and
Gaussian all of those that was really
cool yes yes yes absolutely
mm-hmm so that's mission one we get done
she pulls you out we talked to her for a
little bit now we see all these like
floating figurines are around her and
kind of go through so a lot of so that's
like the opening like mission just kind
of go down in there you see all that
thing then you get into what it takes to
figure out what we have to do yes
so first we're like okay there's an
energy we can't get through it got it
okay we have to solve some way The Hives
seem to be managing with this energy
better than we are how are we doing it
so then we go through and we've got the
collection of the armor do you get your
first piece which is like your mark
which you're like okay I got this but I
can't I can't make any more we got to go
find something else mm-hmm then we go
through and we've got to go back where
we go in the catacombs
right so that's where we actually go
through now in the curtain if I'm wrong
so I'm playing too many things like in
sequence when you play the campaign do
you actually that's you see that you
cross the bridge you go down to the
catacombs
you cross the card Oh BRR
yeah yes so how'd it feel going back
there yeah and I was still waiting for
that back with a form all I got I said
microarray dudes is getting feels right
don't know it did of after that that
mission I was a great mission because
then you had it literally realized
escape or you had to leave that was the
escape and I got the feels also um of
another mission when we got black hammer
for the first time ember that other one
if there was some call back so a lot of
call back for hardcore man it felt good
but that mission particular with the
crota bridge escaping oh that felt good
yeah that was the first time I went
through it was being a buddy and the
first time we went through I straight up
like I died might respond so far back I
was screwed he just kept going he left
me in the dust
if you spawned like you just way there
sweet too much you're not gonna make it
you're not gonna make anything just
bonkers it's insane in me like yeah good
stuff good feel again just nice little
cool oh you know mission beats and stuff
like that that's just done pretty well
but yeah as it went on and then um the I
love the the crotas sister the one that
I can't pronounce with the H I dunno
whatever I love that mission I love that
music
another big elevator yeah just the
aesthetics of the key the sharp edges
the red the scarlet that diem meant like
it felt good you know I'm saying and you
getting up in there yeah man the
missions been a they really played well
the campaign missions really pretty and
I'm get to the point now well I
sometimes I'm getting mad that I wants a
campaign missions are like one and done
like I wish they almost treat it like
strikes in a way and I'm saying yeah
because somebody's need to be replayable
like it was a really really good story
beats yeah the one with the tanks in the
opening there's a whole lot of enemies
to fight you can play replay the story
missions with a little new icon that's
sitting out there now yeah you can
replay it out there that was like one of
the weekly bounty she had you do when
they unlock so you actually replay
through the first mission yes I dig I
did
all right that one's cool but yeah like
after so you got the strike is like one
major bit and now that's just like the
strike is out there and available you
have the opening mission which kind of
takes you through and you see the space
Dorito and then in the middle it's a lot
of stuff on the moon a lot of shooting
things too like killing hive kill and
fall and it's like the collection of
your armor after that because when you
bring back the cripton riff from crypto
glyph sorry yeah you bring that back
from the run you get out of the
catacombs and you're like okay cool we
got it and now you have the lectern of a
chant meant the little floaty vendor
yeah okay that's cool and now you're
starting to create these things and each
one you're going through then you get to
do the other three other nightmare hunts
mm-hmm so now you get to see yep you get
to see omnigul skolas and yes Tanic
school us wasn't annex like ship is back
for its own sake wait a minute school
loss doesn't belong here this is where
tan X would be but that's past with us I
guess that I remember that mission for
black hammer oh yeah man remember that
rumor you had to get out oh but you had
to get to that room and then clear it
and it's funny because it just shows you
the progression of Bungie like how did
they really construct these great
missions for exotics with a timer and
tension and it's it's a very cool
McKenney and that's kind of like what
would we say the black hammer was the
first of its kind secret exotic quest
type thing that required a time yes you
could exactly yeah I think you like this
that sounds right yeah because that was
one of the first like truly timer on
screen things I feel like it's probably
yeah yeah feels right that was the debut
at the end cuz I remember everybody
would like this as hard as it's
challenging I loved it and then they
just kept on with that beat getting
better and better whisper and you know
what zero hour I just love that stuff so
I mean I've definitely become a huge fan
of it but yeah
those missions were really really cool
I'm saying like oh now shout they're
mostly my cheetahs already chasing isn't
it I hope clan is that clear that room
at last second first time I look yeah
man those are the feel-good moments
serious so tight but yeah I really I
really enjoyed just playing through this
campaign and um we got to get to uh I
will say one negative though I did not
this is just me being the fashion war
like elitist why fix your face
Wow why is that dream bein armor net
like that ugly dream painting all that
stuff was growing on you said like
podcast or two ago that it was Berlin
Guerlain on you you know you said that I
did but I didn't feel like I hisses off
here you know when we got sit at home
dreaming city and if I okay The Talisman
well whatever they tell him meet like
they like this armor is special that I
need this to get inside to keep this arm
is not hot enough to be getting this it
need to look better they need to give me
another set to make me go inside the key
chin since over there i lee loves the
dream man said so a good passion is
dream bein said listen i got no hate for
this set know my let that go I just
don't feel that set is worthy to be
entering a key against dramatic exactly
that Party City Robin Batman and Robin
mask that I gotta win should not be
magical enough to get inside this car
looks like it you look like an astro
Shum and just go with that and you'll
and don't go Batman and Robin and you'll
be okay with it I was just hoping for
another set that's all that would be the
one that allowed me to enter the
dimension oh whatever
how many more SEC IV get in the campaign
that we're gonna get plenty of sets but
yeah this you knew you know if they
showed this one off this was gonna be
pretty obvious but yeah see gather the
full set you get up to about 860 with
that then we head back to where went the
first time yes and this time Kurt is not
sitting there on the corner
yeah I'd love the set with an ornament
on it haha very funny yeah there we go
now here you go there you go James
mm-hmm so when you head back in the
second time how did it feel going back
down there I felt I was feels that that
put me in a place I was like yes are you
remember man you're she was doing like
great stuff what about you know it was
second time you go back in we're talking
about going back in the pyramid right go
on back in oh you going there there they
over don't you talk about hellmouth
stuff okay no no no no oh no I mean yeah
like I was just saying we're let's get
to I don't know you talking about the
graph we're in the spoilers we've been
talking about going around the moon yeah
I thought you were yeah I thought you
was take you don't know me we've been on
the moon for about an hour and a half so
yeah you're right you're right that
right there yeah first of all the feel
of it the mystery the anticipation what
the hell is going on you getting pulled
in you like yo what's happening you know
I'm saying the architecture of the ship
you know I'm saying and I don't know if
you saw before you entered there was a
statue almost like you had to do
something you remember that it looked
like a figure of in my mind of what
maybe they could be aka the darkness or
whatever it is this new enemy race I saw
a statue or figure inside there and I
was like yo is this war shouting I'm
gonna say after you got pulled in I
believe there was something where you
have to play something or go up to
something and then you got beamed up but
something happened and I just don't know
my secrets right now excuse me my
sequences off I just I remember it being
inside the ship maybe initially when you
got pulled in there was something I
remember looking at and it looked like a
statue of a large cloaked figure like a
big like it almost like drapes you know
say like a statue so I was like you know
are they foreshadowing how this race
might look because the rumor isn't they
called the veil I mean that's why I was
like d1 concept rumor of the five race
right but
yeah I mean talk about a slow burn by
the way if this thing comes yeah yeah
holy hell bro dad joint got me hi Dan he
had the encounters we had the goal we
had to fire encounters nostalgia field
and I'm gonna get right to it man later
yo when I joined Andy okay I was like
what's happening we are we then you may
pull up you like okay and I'm like
what's goin oh he's like nah like you
got it overall like we you know like it
Jess so I saw vibes comment he wanted a
little bit more it was it was cut it was
cut it was cut abrupt but for me it was
I am dying to do the raid now I feel
that this is literally jumping into cuz
he set it up salvation we know garden
solving like they're mimicking us
they've been watching us what is going
on it was it was a very cool chilling
kind of a see you don't say like what
was your feeling sequence coming in you
know encounter and then that cinematic
what tell me what you felt no I was like
you're going up first then all of a
sudden just get sucked off the cliff you
just like me so you're like flying
through and then as soon as we're flying
through the tunnel that was one of the
small screen shots or blips or something
we saw in one of the trailers for lunch
I was like oh I know this tunnel and I
was like and then you get in there and
as you said the architecture of the ship
is like nothing else I mean the world
design in there is its own completely
different feel which they nailed they
wanted like this is an alien spacecraft
with the space Doritos in the veil it's
like this can't look like anything else
and it didn't which I really really love
you could go like left or right up
through like each side as you progress
through and you like bump into like
first you bump into forget which order
it was was it golf yeah I was golf first
I think golf first yeah golf first and
then
then you phase the fanatic fanatic ya
fanatic and then and then crota you
gotta use the swords that you gotta use
the swords on crota and when you do that
when you do the nightmare huntin Kirti
you gotta use the swords on him too
yeah like that's really cool how they
kept the mechanics back a little bit in
there it's not full raid but like right
you get the feel of like oh we gotta use
the swords okay this is thick mm-hmm
nice touch now before I get to like the
end with the whole black garden scene up
until that point he says salvation yes
it's Garden of salvation that's an
amazing tie-in and honestly like are you
hearing it on two characters honestly
this is by the way the most our
characters spoke in a while yeah oh god
he's just out here talking man
yeah he got words he got a whole voice
box like can't you talk like this is
amazing but I honestly was wondering
mm-hmm
if somebody hasn't been playing destiny
and like hey it's like hey get shadow
keep jump in with me I have a feeling
most of this campaign would has like
next to nowhere near the weight that it
does for you me or anybody psyche I
agree this is full nostalgia hip but for
like a new player be like oh you got it
you want to play in shadow group they're
like who what what what are those they
what are all these things that were
fight like the nightmare hunts we see
and they talk about like crow two
slaughtered you know thousands or
whatever and you had Gaul doing his
crazy stuff and then the fanatic like
there's the voiceovers as you go through
the ship that say like kind of what
happened but if you didn't play if you
don't have a history in this game this
is like this is over your head by am I
agree that's a great point that's a
great point and I think people who are
going to detract from this dlc and let's
say give it a low review or say again
Tasi has a great article I get it you
know people who have not played destiny
at all you've been away for a while you
know maybe from the beginning you jump
in you're gonna like okay I don't know
what's going on but to me it's like I'm
not gonna like this is a not a one to
one comparison so please bear with me it
is like how I look at how in-game is
from the Avengers and it says you had to
been watching all the way to get the
little nuances you know I'm saying
that's how I feel this is
it's deeper than game no I'm saying but
what I'm trying to say this is a
hardcore destiny fans love letter
that's what shall keep is to me as far
as destroyed is it the best or am I
saying you know it's better than
forsaken and it's better I'm not going
there I'm just saying as far as
nostalgic beats and where the story
needs to go we've been wanting this and
to be honest we didn't think we would
even see these guys until d3 so to see
that [ __ ] just nestled in that moon
ominous like yo all this time like it
really evokes emotion for people who've
been following the Lord I want to know
about the darkness to know why it's here
then you here's a viola mentioning the
collapse you know I'm saying and what
they went through like you're hearing
that the other NPCs talk about you know
so it just puts in this whole thing
about Yoda travelers in trouble fam like
the travelers everything is intial ever
since that thing kicked off in it like
we are in serious trouble
these guys are not to be trusted we
don't know what's going on and I just
felt mysterious and cool I liked it man
I really did I'm not gonna say the
greatest or oh my god you know I'm
saying but for a hardcore destiny fan
you've been wanting advancement and we I
felt we got at least advancement and I
feel the rate to me that the key is now
the raid how it ties in then we got vex
offensive how it ties in that to me is
gonna determine where shadow keep ranks
and I'm saying right now absolutely yeah
bare bones we're still a lot to learn
still a lot to feel if you want to rip
it and say rehash content no I don't get
fine you know I'm saying but I gotta see
where this thing is gonna go because I'm
excited of the potential of where it
could go so that's where I'm at with it
I mean you cannot take the words out of
my mouth their potentials what I'd like
the biggest thing we see in the space
Doritos for the first time I was like oh
this door is now open so as you see but
honestly we haven't seen the race so
they haven't had to design a race yet we
just have an architecture of a ship
that's so it's like the t's is there
like the nostalgic throwbacks were
awesome as you go through playing
through the fights the crota dealing
with gali or like just got done doing
this a couple years ago so now we're
back but yes stand in the black garden
talking to yourself it's like we're not
your friend we're not your enemy or your
salvation and you're like you're in the
garden of salvation like what so again
I'm still hoping what you hope well
when the raid is completed that's when
the FEC's offensive begins hoping those
who are tied I'm hope it's not just like
ghoulia I'm just hoping Saturday excuse
me hoping Saturday both don't turn on at
the same time moving raid and then it's
like yeah yeah that'll be nice that'd be
nice because that way they yeah there
was the same way they before sake it was
like you beat the raid now we're in this
three week cycle yeah that I'm pretty
confident it's gonna be that I'm pretty
confident that's like it fit silliest
yeah it fits the matically and then I
want to know to me now the question
becomes why are the vex hell-bent on
like just pulling up well what's going
like do why are they in full gorilla
mode and I'm saying like what is going
on so I got to see that whole tie-in
this is very I'd just have a lot of
story be questions man they went the
whole this mystery race and I'm excited
just to see where it where it goes and
what the what the final what that rate
shirts gonna be what is that yeah let's
see it's very yeah very curious what
that is mmm so Saturday is tomorrow so
we get to see what happens in 24 12 just
about 24 hours pretty damn rows grind it
out see what else you can get up there
see how close you get mm-hmm I'm
probably not gonna go through the race
but I'm sure I'll watch as I go through
I do want to jump in at least the first
ticket yeah I'll be attempting the first
encounter for sure in a second depending
on how it goes but it's like we'll see
light levels at least I mean 919 on my
warlock just literally one more oh you
good I was like but my was like I just
gotta figure out what to infuse cuz all
my weapons right now every single one is
absolute trash so I mean that's pretty
close I'm like yeah spoiler spoiler
/ I think we're probably pretty good you
want to go full off no more spoilers
yeah yeah crazy hand-wave no more
spoilers don't have spoilers okay
spoilers over yes but oh yeah um yeah I
think um you know we got this raid dying
I am curious I am trying to keep
expectations in check but I just curious
for the story beats you know who beats
it how that goes
you got me more excited now that I
qualify for a damp jacket so I'm gonna
try it again ten days you can still go
for it you know I'm shooting Tuesday
Wednesday the latest I would like to get
thing done you know says yeah keep this
train rolling but um so far so good
so far so good with shadow keep you know
I curious to see what happens next man
yeah so I guess final bits for me as I
keep thinking of stuff as I go through
when it comes to armor 2.0 we haven't
actually talked about it that much
details why it's like what do you feel
about like potential there do you think
there's enough do you like do you like
how the mods are gonna get rolled out do
you think it's gonna be slow do you
think like once we have on the mods then
you're just like kind of good like what
are your thoughts on just the armor 2.0
piece just cuz honestly I hadn't I have
no of that deep I've just been I've been
in it so much I haven't thought of
everything I've been playing around now
soul it today was on I'm a 2.0 mess
around day and I've been getting a lot
of it I like it you know I do like they
do it's definitely structured in a way
where they're trying to promote balance
cuz you know clearly you got to six to
the seven range there's some mods like I
got a lot of intellect mazels costs 5
out of the energy you know I'm saying so
it's like boo if you put that there then
you can't get these other things you can
only get the one pieces here and there
I do like that certain things from the
season track you know allow a +1 out you
have to put those on just cuz you unlock
didn't rank you still have to unlock it
and put it on in placement I felt the
price to add stuff almost cheap one
thing that felt weird but good at the
same time was again I'm playing with my
reg Rick oh the artifact
yes the artifact season-best site
correct correct
just overall with Mars I'm talking
weapon for a second but just to flip a
switch and let you know what I don't
like um rampage back on this I'm gonna
put this it just felt weird like you're
so used to have the sacrifice and break
I'm like do I have anymore let me just
make sure I put something we confer oh
it's still there okay yeah so that was
cool on weapons but back to armor um
it's early my only concern II is I think
they tried to elongate it by having the
different elements right so you gotta
get this element to get this one or that
one to get that one my only concern is
when we get the majority of these what
is to play you don't say like it's there
is it just have everything I'm I'm more
concerned in a long game I think short
term we're fine
yep I just want to see long term hardest
thing is you know I'm saying but the
biggest thing to me transmog man oh yeah
easy to its being the feels brother oh
yes playing with a buddy of mine and
I'll it literally through on me just the
last ever versed it was the full Optimus
II I threw on some like blue monarchy
new monarchy shader because it's just
what I had through the same one on my
sparrow and I was like look I actually
got fashion game he's like first time in
like five years good job I've never
carried because I know you always pick
function over fashion people oh no no no
if I got like this one up here let's go
like rocket launcher loader and this one
over here this rocket launcher scavenger
and they don't look like eight I don't
care I haven't because it's I was like
if I've got like if the function is
their fashion is not my thing it never
has been but if I can do it that easily
then yeah now I'll toy around with stuff
but welcome to the life brother this is
what it feels like
we got a style baby you gotta look good
at everything you do and now you got the
ability just press that look cuz I was
freaking out I was like questions what
matter what somebody's
you just press down on you and I'm like
oh sorry Chan's mom that coming hey all
it felt so good especially to turn on
Glee gear into something nice
Oh nobody never dreamed beta Armour look
like whatever you want so you're fine
turned off that nastiness and put on
some hot oh it's good it was good man it
felt good so transmog I'm deaf I would
like more more options too
I want that to increase I want more yeah
thank you some people on Twitter were
just saying like why isn't every
legendary set that I've got just in an
ornament as well like yes pick them all
let me goof everyone let's let's get
crazy you know saying I think they will
they've got up they had a lot to do this
launch this is this is this is where my
theme is with shadow key you know and we
complain a little bit about you know the
vendor refreshing all this is rightful
stuff but in their defense
yo they've had a lot to accomplish in
one launch this is a different type of a
launch that's why I can't I'm a little
bit more forgiving to say and I competed
compare it with the they're taking Kings
in the for saying cuz to me those are
the high bar you know for me you know
but for everything that's encompassing
in this expansion and new light and
players and cross they even you know I'm
saying all these systems and things this
was a lot and on their own on their own
you know I'm saying like this is a lot
so to me I think the foundation is great
I think 2.0 can have some legs you know
I'm saying I just want to see what else
they do to add it but it feels good I
just I just want more my what what
scavenger Birds or what but has anyone
confirmed that the the super arm anomaly
like yeah no not that one I intellect
remember the ones that used to be like
um puffer and yeah
they will be there you just have I want
no yes anyone confirmed seeing them I
haven't looked honestly okay that's what
I mean that's not one of those Ling's
yeah I don't know if there's like a
checklist you're gonna work through or
if it's just like random on the mods
because might have been all over the
place the ones I've seen it is so and it
truly does the pin you've got the solar
the arctan the void so you're limited
there
my a thing that I've kind of wondered
cuz we had like tier 1 and tier 2 and
they said previously it was like go back
if you like you can get the vex
offensive set from the season pass and
you'll get the ornaments which is fine
but it's like Eddy there was that quote
where is like going to the vex offensive
and you can get better stats I'm like
everything I'm seeing I got one that was
like 55 SATs and it felt like a god role
cuz everything else is like basically 48
to 52 they all feel the same and I'm
just like I want to know that like
higher difficulty drops higher stats and
that stuff we don't know yet because you
haven't seen here oh we haven't seen
legend we haven't seen those things back
so I wanted to know that that is that's
my biggest thing about armor because
that's the other side of the grind the
mods are one thing you're eventually
gonna have a set that's void asset
that's archanis at that solar you'll
have those you know you'll have them
mm-hmm you can interchange for the guns
that you need but eventually my big
piece is like I want to know that that
stat grind can't improve because of the
cap is 60 on everything that really
shoots one of those pieces of the grind
hard yeah so that's that's why though
I'm pretty confident based on the little
beats we've gotten you know again just
doing little missions and getting stuff
in specific places I think it's gonna be
one of those to me the vibe they've
consistently been on is pinnacle
activity pinnacle activity rewards
rewards right give you the best rewards
I think it's gonna be one of those cases
that you know when we do those those
grinds that it that will give us you
know kind of what we need so we're
saying we'll see you know but III hey
what you going you got valid points yeah
so that's it but I mean overall like
this the other switching mods on armors
cheap it's like five hundred switching
weapon mods is five thousand glimmer
don't do that too often that's a little
more expensive oh yeah how long did it
once yeah oh yeah but I mean but still
it's just like in glimmer the 250 cap
you know just layin naturally got up
there I will say the pre-order ghost
that's been paying off dividends with
those chests said like XP and glimmer on
the munoz like perfect combo I'm sorry
that so I've been really good overall
like the finishers are great additions I
think the cost of
the amount of super they cost is gonna
be I know they want you to make a
decision
mm-hmm but if it was what's the heavy
one eventually is it half if you get out
there on the mod on the artifact I mean
and for Cherie when that's one-third now
yeah it's a third and that's just
special bricks I'm like I'll go kill a
random like red bar and he'll drop to
special breaks like is my super worth
that yeah that's good and that's because
special energy is like yeah you got like
your normal snipers you're not talking
about whispers you're not talking about
Darcy like the heavy I see having some
weight in it for the whole team being
team breaking I could see him but it's
like like a quarter of your super for
like one break a heavy like that'd be
nice just to control cuz I mean quarter
takes a little while I don't know even
if the heavy brick for you was a third
but it was like a third for the special
I think the weights on some of these
like it was a blow off yeah they're
little off like the tenth for primary
ammo and reloading all your weapons is
actually not bad
that's not bad I got no the primary and
then the quit the reload after a finish
that's actually solid for a tenth I'm
like that's not a big chunk that yeah I
think they're just waited a little heavy
right now and I think that's just be
maybe and it's just a balance things
balancing thing they're like err on a
sarah caution mag you know I know I'm
just saying like things yeah they got to
keep it there but overall I think I
think maybe that'll need to get tweaked
a little bit okay but I think right I
mean I like some of them I've only got a
couple so far I got one I forget what it
was like it might have been a quarter or
a fifth or some random number you do a
finisher and your grenade comes back yep
I got that one yeah I was like if I
dunno it was random I'm is could have
been anywhere from a loss sector to a
nightmare hunt to a package I don't know
I
but yeah it's like you can go like I
think you're just like hey let me do
don't don't die hold on let me finish
you get my grenade throw it out there
shoot this so it's like you got a low
health a lot of people but you can like
you could burn that super and go throw
like three or four grenades out like if
you want if the finisher synergy it's it
adds a little new wrinkle to destiny
yeah I like it
like I got the one that you said with
the primary ammo in the thing I got that
I got one just nice to use all the time
just yeah with the reload and all that
that's move I got on I was the other one
oh man you've made one before it I have
that one the other one is you what
what's the ones you have I think I have
like special ammo I think I have a good
one yeah so I mean those are good the
heavy is gonna be on the artifact trying
to think what else there's one where if
you do finishers you can get glimmer
from it that one's on the ei that one's
on the artifact so if you do that like
how are you doing on your artifact in
general like how is your specking are
you feeling but we really talk about
artifact like how are you feeling about
artifacts backing and where that's at uh
I mean it's not bad I just threw like a
enhance reload on there and I was like
what a hamster reload uh for him can't I
like hand cannons are slow as hell by
the way with no reload perks at all like
because if you don't have outlaw or
hurry and you don't have reload speed so
I was like I just threw in an enhanced
reload I was like this doesn't feel that
much faster I'm like and then I played
once without law I'm like oh it's the
combination of both that's always like a
beast but it was like yeah the reload
speed for being one is cheap but they
are definitely steering you to those
weapons so I'll see how the future
artifacts play out but no I think I
don't know like I'm I was stuck on like
the for a second yeah I I played on my
Titan up to like level five or six I
think I'd unlocked a few but it's like
I'm kind of getting that point where I'm
not sure what I want to spend on because
the resets only 10,000 so I don't know
yeah so I need I add some point justice
pin that's about that yeah I was gonna
it's gonna escalate as a reset by the
way really yeah it's gonna get more
expensive so you don't want to do it a
lot so when you reset do you get those
unlocks back when you have earned them
ago you don't have to turn them again
you just reset the placement of them now
you have a choice of that artifact is it
locked between character your mods that
you unlock our different per character
so I'll owe it to my warlock my second
character my artifact is zero of eight
unlocks done my Titan uh picked them all
so you can't make a choice between the
character like hey if this one's better
for a void synergistic build or this
one's Arco
over here and some of them are you like
hunk like you can mix those up a little
bit which is nice you have the freedom
but overall mm I mean I don't think it's
game breaking I haven't got to that
final tier yet let me come at like 8 or
9 so I'm not and the final like game
breaking moments I'm waiting to see how
those will do but I think overall it's
just it's fun the barrier and those
things paired with the nightmares and
the night falls those are what we're
gonna be mostly is gonna be where you
have to have those things I'm like do
you just get all 5 so you have options
and it's like I don't have my I don't
have my loadout yet so I don't know
which Murad's I want I know Ariana
technically as a hand cannon with
barrier so it's a new barrier that's
Auto and subs so I have like flash
ability I'm gonna do I did the
unstoppable because it's the only one
for hand cannons is the unstoppable one
have you used that yet by the way I have
not so you literally you loaded up you
80s for a second it gets this like kind
of light sheen over the gun
that bullets now loaded with unstoppable
and then when you fire instantly
staggers the target nice so even the
unstoppable and is the whole point of it
but even if it's just like a knight's
running at you still stagger them so the
like oh it is it will stagger an enemy
it's not just for those but it is I
thought it was only for that yeah oh
nice toe yeah but that's I think that
might be the only one that works that
way because I don't know if you can
disrupt the other ones with like the
overload the way you can the minutes are
rough you can disrupt another type so I
haven't tested all that stuff but I have
like the top middle in the bottom for
that column mm-hmm and then the middle
ones all your reloads and then I hadn't
gotten said uh
they get kind of the one start getting a
little more kind of game changes where
if you disrupt something you get a
benefit from it or if a teammate does
theirs those start getting to more than
disrupts and overloads and then the last
ones like you're crazy finishers so
those are big God should know yeah I've
been like I've been you know it's been
cool
I've been still messing around with Alma
to play no I haven't even messed around
with the the resist stuff yet have you
messed around with the major resist des
resist
I mean I throw those on like just all
the time so okay I mean those are yeah
your generic mods for like rifle
reloader and stuff like I've got enough
glimmer and shards but I can take most
armor up to about five energy for
intercept or you leave them right about
five yeah I'm not spending anything
above
I feel oh it's not not feel like
Saturday until you're like okay how much
can I pack in here but yeah yeah that's
that's kind of the enhancement cores are
those way they suck you out right there
oh yeah they act like to two per a whop
and all you go to - but then you're
talking about the prisms dude the people
if they those the prisms cost 10 cores
and then the shards cost 10 prisms hmm
that is insane
that's insane you know we'd even talk
about and I forgot all about this how do
you feel real quick I know we go along
Long Point yeah um
how you feel about upgrade module we
didn't know we didn't so I'm not what I
would probably have like 15 or 18 now
from the levels I've gone through they
are a cheaper purchase than previous
infusions they brought the cost down a
little bit now you sell the planetary
mushara materials charts and glimmer
but overall the infusion because
sometimes it was like 2 or whatever it's
literally at one core I think well yeah
just what I mean it's they've improved
that some and it just kind of unifies it
it is like one more currency that you
have to have which is like right come on
right but they did cheap an infusion a
little bits they give you those in the
free pass of I mean so those are nice
overall I'm kind of I'm okay it just I
guess the like ban she'll probably go
through a rotation of like hey me
atheism it was that he's gonna go
through those but when you look at
something you're just like hey won't
upgrade it's a module like it's
amplifies your inventory but when it
takes to when it comes to buying those
we'll see I just I don't know the only
places I see those are buying them from
banshee for the currency or the season
pass mop this season Pratt and his arm
you know what you can get him his weekly
um
reward if you look at the rewards you'll
just in there - those seem to be the
sources that I've seen you know yeah
you're gonna have to be a little stingy
on the infusion for a little while
unless you just want to blow through all
the materials but overall I think it's
think it's a reasonable step in a better
direction I mean they're still going to
be for
people they're gonna be like hey this
thing's you know down here like
seven-year 780 it was a cool roll good
I'll see you later
like you'll be doing that for a little
while but and then the raid race people
they've been farming everything they
don't care they're just gonna blow
everything for the raid race and then
they'll stick it back up but for the end
of its person it's a little cheaper and
I think it's it simplifies the inventory
but when you get them hopefully people
kind of put those two together so yeah I
think you nailed it I think that's
literally how I feel about it I like
that it's simplified I like to destroy
one I didn't feel that cost was too
excessive you know I like that he had an
option when I went there he was at oh
you don't have zero spirals you can use
your data wise did you know Maddie never
use that with the core I mean with the
intercept Dana lice Oh No somebody I
heard so many things say Dana lettuce I
was like that's actually the best one
how is it pronounced E you toe it was
just it was data data lattice is what I
do that is okay yeah so lettuce like a
framework but no you just had lice I'm
like are we talking about head bugs like
if she up here now you know just get
pics man that's what I got overall enjoy
it and I'm looking forward to tomorrow
man yeah so like next week it's gonna
open up some things we'll start to see
the hero nightmare hunts next week on
Tuesday we've got the vex offensive
which will be a whole different
discussion next week potentially as long
as it should be heads up to all you guys
next week should be an evening podcast
yeah because we're gonna have scare Oh
back on so the man of the last word
started this thing and we took the reins
nicely but he is gonna be coming back as
a guest he has been out there crushed in
it by the way I don't know if you've
seen him on Twitter like his light
levels up there he's like jumping in the
raid I know he's been playing with fire
a lot dude he's got like a new raid
buddy so like they're like oh yeah so
nope I'll be curious to see cuz he's
gonna have a lot of stuff to talk about
cuz he's like neck deep in the grind
he's hardcore and so no he that will be
a fun one next week that'll be an
evening so stay tuned on Twitter or you
know YouTube come all those places for
it timing will kind of nail that one
down as we get
like a Friday evening type thing but
other than that yeah I'm in the same
place I've like enjoyed it so far I've
had a really good time there's more
things that I want to see and I think
they had a lot on their plate and they
delivered what they could I just don't
think they delivered everything that
everybody wanted I agree so yeah there's
always things I wish they could have
added I always you know there's things
that could be more there could be more
perks on weapons there could be more
vendor refreshes there could be more
this that in the other but overall I
think they've launched what they're
excited with is a great place to head
into the future definitely definitely
Matt I'm with you bro my thoughts
exactly and I cannot wait like I said
not only tomorrow to the progression of
this DLC and then I can kind of
formulate a better picture of overall
but everything you said thus far is in
my opinion very accurate about the state
of shadow keep right now nice but yeah
that's pretty much all I got I know we
did kind of our outros or at least I did
mine what do you got for yours anything
else I might be making a guest
appearance this weekend all right about
two six nine like I said on Twitter for
those who do not know and um yeah man
iron ore podcast every Sunday we're on
football season time so 11:00 a.m.
Eastern we will have special guest mr.
bad--but from the PlayStation trophy
cast so we gonna have some good Sony
representation in the building we will
be talk he's also a destiny fan so it
will be nice I warned him I was like
this is going to be a lot of destiny on
this ILP because of those who don't know
I love podcast with the name should give
it away is definitely founded as a
destiny only cast initially but then we
moved into multiply and then making his
potential return all bearing schedule
works out if the schedule works out yeah
the last
words own cheater will be in the
building hopefully so hopefully we can
get e in there I got some nice cooked up
from so it'll be cool you're no Lord
cockney loves is intro so I'm mad we'll
see how it goes if your schedule allows
we definitely welcome em you know we got
more key and at that point we can have a
different perspective because the rate
will be most likely completed hopefully
by that point I'll be almost a full 24
hours yeah at that point so we would
assume they won't be over nine twenty
more o2 again so I know I know all now
situation that was crazy you really
wanted s hopefully someone does it you
know with the contest rules and stuff
like that but yeah it would be good if
he bounces his schedule out I know he's
been killing it his eyes are tired but
we shall see if it comes back to the
realms of the Lord late today that's
about it guys think we said it earlier
you guys can find me everywhere with a
stream in here on YouTube on Twitter
let's look at the giveaway going and
just more content will be coming from me
so just guides and tips and pointers and
helpful things for new players and all
that type of stuff so lots more stuff
that I can pretty much always be
recording so it's between playing and
recording so if you find me online I've
been editing videos online too just for
entertainment value because I'm like I
haven't wrapped that one up last night I
was like well I'll hang out with you
guys while I do this last piece so yeah
last night was late so we got this I
honestly don't know for one if sir is
gonna be I hope he's on like mercury or
Mars or the Dreaming city please tell me
he can go everywhere
there isn't a shadow to eat that's fine
if he's in the shadow I was like but I
want him to be able to because now
literally everybody can land on every
planet yeah so sir can now be on it
there's no DLC distinctions oh yeah so
what you hope you like him in city or so
would you I mean of course the moon
would be a good place to start to kick
it off but I mean I want to see where he
I want to see him on the Dreaming city I
want to see him on yeah I want to find
those spots cuz finally actually might
have put sir on the moon yeah so I mean
I'm hoping he's not just like up he's
uneasy again like I want him to be
everywhere yeah I don't know if he's
gonna
anything new so that'll be in an hour
and 11 minutes so that's right things
will be a little delayed today just
because this is a big boy podcast mmm
other than that yeah as like sirs come
in so we'll see if he has any tweaks for
the weekend if he has any helpful Ted
bits and then the raids tomorrow
so you guys can watch some garden of
salvation guarded of salvation I'm gonna
at least jump in at noon I'm gonna see
what this thing's all about so I'll be
right here streaming are you gonna you
got a match I will be on xbox with Loren
addict hopefully Lord sinister deaf
singer shout to him and maybe to maybe
uh nautical he might join us below him
he might join us so we got a decent team
look he's in his world first man I'm
like look right good luck to do the best
we can like I know guys haven't been
practicing playing together you know you
are like a well-oiled machine that's no
I'm sorry
I understand how these things go and I
listen I never want to crush anyone's
dream and I would never I told him I'm
just a realist
that's all I'm a realist I know how this
thing is just where it will be there and
I still got light level to work on and
to be honest you know my thing is just
coming in in with the right pilled and I
think I have a good bill but again it's
communication its strategy we don't know
what we're gonna face we don't know
that's where things get crazy and things
break down sometimes but I hope we try
my best
it's go ahead blackberries extra extra
square it's that yeah I will be on xbox
you already know you can finally same as
my name Lord Cognito everywhere I'm Lord
floorspace kognito on xbox I'm come on
what you call it on Steam of course and
shut up testy PlayStation new light was
flawless it was great man it's I brought
my guardian right over there and it
promptly told me you don't have forsaken
over here and you can only do XY and Z
but luckily did I already have my
subclass club checkup classes that's not
locked out you can still play with that
because I already have Oh somewhere else
yeah yeah so that was you know that Oh
second lesson so you can't go like raid
on ps4
yeah new light properly told me you
don't own shadow keep you can pull up
with the moon you can land you can you
can land in the area forsaken wait until
you make those purchases on this
platform sir you
we'll be a spectator yeah so that's what
like yeah so it's been an awesome one
guys I'm gonna send you guys over to k
UJ awesome pvp guy and shout out to the
J Alex out there cuz I'm one of those um
so say hey to him for us over there for
the raid of twitch but thank you guys
it's been awesome this morning for
episode 76 it has been the post - shadow
keep launch episode it is October 4th
and for ebon Tess and Lord Cognito it
has been the last word